Me,
as we prayed,
sadness that I tell you that this Joe
Rogan experience is not brought to you by
the fleshlight.
We've come to the end of our long road
with the flashlight and they've been.
They were the first sponsor ever on
the Joe Rogan experience podcast and we
appreciate the fuck out of that.
They took a chance when
we were on a laptop,
what snowflakes in the background,
and we did two hard years together
and we hope to really hard years.
We hope that we sold you
a lot of fake pussies.
That's what we sincerely hope.
We hope that our relationship
was profitable and we
just want to say that you
guys are cool as fuck and we enjoyed
working with you and best of luck and all
you do with your rubber pussies in the
future if you have a solid product.
And it was an honor to represent you to
the field of battle sharing this moment
of silence real quick.
Okay.
Do what?
What mobile ready?
Okay.
We're good.
We're,
uh,
we're not sponsored by alienware.
People keep asking because
we changed the laptops.
We only are doing this because I think
it's a good idea to support companies who
support mma and alien ware to
stepped up and they them and Dell.
That's a big deal.
When a company like alienware
start sponsoring fighters.
I mean when I see that alien
logo on fighters shorts,
that's a big deal.
To me.
It's like that's a big fucking company.
Like an Anderson Silva was burger king.
I don't eat burger king,
but if I was going to eat burger king,
I would eat burger king because
they sponsored Anderson Silva.
Not that Andersen needs it as much as
like mma gets a lot of these fighters,
what they get in,
how they get
money for training and to pay for.
It's not just their
salaries from fighting,
it's from their sponsors.
So if you see young guys
and they're fighting,
you know,
for 10,000 bucks or whatever it is,
it's not.
You don't get paid a lot of money
when nobody knows who you are.
You get paid a lot of money
when you can sell tickets.
But what keeps these young guys going is,
especially companies like alienware,
like really high profile companies,
when they start putting
the logos on your shorts,
that's.
That means that there's a
big company that's invested,
there's a big company
and it's stepping up.
I think that should be rewarded and that's
why we decided to do this and we're,
we're working with sucker
punch entertainment and
alienware MMA and they hooked
us up with some laptops and we're trying
to support a company that supports mma.
And by the way,
these are not cheap laptops.
They're fucking expensive,
but they kick some serious ass if
you want to play games on laptops,
these things,
the shit.
And people are like,
well you can make yourself for cheaper.
I maybe you could make a laptop,
I don't know how you could buy shells
for laptops and you can kind of do it,
but you're not going to make a fucking
alien if you can afford it though.
They are the shit.
I mean these,
the frame rates and these
things are ridiculous.
So you know,
you watch full resolution on these things,
but they're very fun when I'm using it.
Even Three d,
which is a fucking trip
when you're really,
really baked in,
you want to play some games
in three D in your bed.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a very solid gaming
laptop and we support them.
We support a alienware period for nothing
for free or sort of sort of free shit
and laptops.
Get a little money out of it.
So,
uh,
we are also sponsored
by [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain.
I haven't even mind yet.
Fuck.
I'm getting insecure now.
Did you hear that on it?
Rattle snake.
Is that the onnit rattlesnake?
I'm Scott.
My battle rope.
Just got battle ropes in the mail.
It'll tell me some of the time.
Your brain time to get
caveman style in the backyard.
Scare the neighbors,
you know,
bitches know.
Yeah.
When you hear your neighbor to
kettlebells in the backyard here,
that's dude like you
probably not gonna wanna.
Invite that guy.
Barbecue.
Fucking Weirdo.
Especially human noise.
You make me uncomfortable.
Like when we go work out together,
if you look,
if you're working out correctly,
it's really hard,
you know,
you gotta work out to the point where
your body's failing to with a ball gag in
her mouth and they basically
have something like that.
They have this thing called the training
mask and a Bas rutten has one called
the boss.
I think it's the boss.
Oh,
something or another.
And it's um,
you breathe through it
and it restricts your air.
It gives you like tiny
air holes to breathe,
right?
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
Bas rutten's sits in
your mouth kind of crazy,
like this big giant mouthpiece and,
but the,
the,
the other one,
the elevation mask is like,
it's got like little hoses on it and shit.
And when boss routines and
very controversial by the way,
scientifically not really
supported it's support,
it's not really supported that that
improves your oxygen and it doesn't,
it certainly doesn't do.
So.
Taking capacity out
training at altitude does,
which training it to does is you live
in a place and you stay overnight and
sleep in a place where
there's a very high altitude,
very low oxygen,
your body naturally overproduces red
blood cells to compensate for the lack of
oxygen.
That doesn't mean that when
you restrict your oxygen,
your body makes more red blood cells.
It just means it's harder to breathe.
I mean,
it's kind of a better workout,
but it's also kind of not a better workout
because you're not able to work out
as hard because you can't breathe as hard,
you know,
so unless you're an
absolutely perfect shape,
the benefit of it is probably negligible.
I don't know what the fuck
this has to do with anything,
but uh,
that's why wouldn't work out with a ball
gag that would love to hear you like
doing your [inaudible].
Like when you don't have a ball
gag in and you're working out,
it sounds sexual sounds really intense.
No to everybody in the gym,
like girls are like fucking like,
listen,
son.
Pushing out to the elliptical.
If you're going to do it,
you should do it.
Guys are.
If you're going to do it,
you should actually.
I know I can't actually.
I don't want to have a
halfassed workout ever.
I don't.
I don't believe in those.
I think if you're going to work out,
you should work out.
If you got to work out,
you gonna make some noise.
Yeah.
It'll be scared.
It sounds very grapey.
It was planet fitness places.
Those are the worst where
you're not allowed to Moan.
Have you seen those places?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You're.
You're literally not around the grunt.
We don't take.
They call you a meathead
if you grunt tool.
Right?
Like if it wasn't sexual sounds,
it would not be illegal.
Bunch of Limp Dick dudes that
don't want guys to get too strong.
That is this some weird fucking
gyms for insecure people?
Yeah.
Like you don't want to.
It's one thing.
There are dudes that go way too crazy.
This guys who use it know
where they get together,
quotes,
go
this guys at the gym where
it becomes uncomfortable.
Like,
come on you bitches.
What do you do that you just make loud
sexual noises that echo out throughout 24
hours.
If you're going to deadlift,
you should be making some fucking noise.
Do you guys still yell?
Lightweight.
Now what does that Ronnie Coleman,
Ronnie Coleman used to yell out.
Lightweight,
lightweight.
I used to hear that Shit in the gym.
It was noisy.
I don't understand it like that was what
he would say to psych himself up for a
big lift.
Like,
oh the.
Oh,
the guys in the gym.
All these Ronnie Coleman
wannabes chanting that.
That guy was so big when he was big.
Jesus Christ was Ronnie Coleman big.
He was big like what?
He was a cop.
He was doing it.
That was the really nuts shit about that.
Can you Mr. Olympia Guy,
he was so fucking big.
Jesus Christ.
That guy was huge.
He had a big smile and I can
imagine being pulled over by him.
You see that and I bet he was
a decent officer a lot anymore.
He got all his aggressions out
in the gym to get that big.
You have to work out so fucking hard.
I don't care what you're taking does,
it doesn't just make you grow.
Like that guy is working out really hard.
There's something going
on outside of steroids.
There's a lot of hard work there,
so he was probably tired all
the time to smile and know.
Always constantly.
If you're built like the hulk,
you know much fucking cowards.
You have to scarf down and just to stay,
stay afloat anyway.
What brought to you by the fuck you doing
brought to you by [inaudible] dot com.
A makers of Alpha brain
and as we were saying,
I just got the battle ropes in the mail.
Kettlebells are in,
if you haven't used kettlebells to work
out is my personal favorite exercise and
someone corrected me on my
message board there actually.
Right?
They said that.
I always say that a bench
presses and isolation exercise.
It does work.
A bunch of different muscle groups.
When,
I mean is it sort of.
It's an unnatural sort of a thing to
just be doing this and what I like about
kettlebells is that it requires
you to use your whole body.
I mean,
when you bench press,
I guess you could push off the ground
with your feet and it does have some sort
of impact.
Suddenly I'm against bench press.
I mean I still do conventional
weightlifting to occasionally,
but I think that for me personally,
the,
the.
If I had one piece of workout
equipment that I would choose to use,
it will be the Kettlebell because you can
get an amazing workout with a 30 pound
Kettlebell.
I mean just break your body down and
credit the kind of endurance strain that's
like,
like training Jujitsu,
like when someone's
trying to strangle you,
like it's the only thing that comes
close to making you that hard.
It's an incredible workout and just a
35 pound Kettlebell and it strengthens
your whole body,
strengthens your core,
your abs,
your legs,
and you really don't.
It's not that difficult to like
formulate a workout program.
You can go look at some of
them that are on Youtube.
There's a bunch of guys who
have great dvds out there.
Mike Mauler is a great one.
He's got a great DVD.
My friend Steve Maxwell,
fantastic dvds out there.
There's always workouts that you can
find and you can watch a DVD and follow
along with it and literally getting
the best fucking shape of your life.
They're amazing for for like
actual physical usable strength.
Like if you do anything that requires
physical strength and you do kettle bells,
it'll make it better.
It's really incredible.
It just makes your body just stronger
as a unit as opposed to like say like
bicep curls.
That would be a true isolation exercise.
Something that's really unnatural where
you just only really using the biceps
and maybe a little bit of
the forums like he bought.
He doesn't really want to move like that.
Your body wants to pick things up and
move as a unit and that in my opinion,
is the best way for fitness
to get your body stronger,
to do full body exercises
like Turkish getups.
I mean they're not as
romantic as bicep curls,
man.
It is true.
It's like bicep curls or sex.
Why he screams and moans
about it yet and that's why
it gets wet.
You know,
there's something sexy about it.
There's something sexy about a.
because if a guy's just working as buys,
always trying to do is look good.
Every man in the gym is having
an emotional experience.
Some level.
Yes.
That's why I will not do.
If you do it right,
you've got to get really uncomfortable,
man.
Do it right.
You've got to feel like shit.
Oh by my favorite way to feel
like shit is with kettlebells.
It feels like shit.
And then I feel awesome afterwards.
That and a Hindu squats.
A lot of you've been saying,
you've been sending tweets about that.
You started doing the Hindu squats
and what a big difference it makes.
It's fucking incredible.
It's one of the best exercises you can do.
You don't need a gym,
Hindu squats.
I do 200 of them before I do any
workout and I am feel like stopping.
I feel like I'm done at just
200 squats with no weight.
You would think there's no
way that's going to be easy.
That's so easy.
It's not.
It's fucking hard and it
gets hard at around like 60,
like around 60 like shit.
And then you're in a seven and then you
hit a hundred and you're like another
100 of these bitches.
It's fucking great to do and it's
not like a high weight exercise.
It develops your leg strength without
really putting yourself in a precarious
positions with weights on your back.
So it's a good way to start a base of,
uh,
of training as well.
And so like if you,
if you're not really a guy,
works out at all and you're thinking,
man,
I want to get in shape,
don't go crazy.
And just immediately start doing squats.
Our friend Kevin Pereira was
in here yesterday and he's
all fucked up because of
that very reason because
he didn't work out.
And then all of a sudden he was doing
crazy fucking power lifts three times a
day.
Anyway,
point is go to [inaudible] dot com.
This is our only sponsor.
We'll have one sponsor
now on it is the spa.
We only have one sponsor.
He has still managed to have a
15 fucking minutes commercial.
Three dream sponsors.
What would your three dream sponsors be?
We'd have to think about that.
Let's think about that,
Jack Daniels,
number one,
that would be to have to evolve from
the flashlight to the real doll,
don't you?
It's not evolution.
The real deal is creepy
as fuck the fleshlight.
You just putting something over your Dick.
The real dollars.
You're pretending that a woman.
Isn't that a relative?
Creepiness?
Yes,
totally relevant,
but the actual fiber of
the fleshlight is superior.
Supposedly.
I shouldn't say fiber texture.
Yeah,
but have you ever used a Jack
Daniels bottle as a flashlight?
My Dick is way too big for that now.
Now if you break it off at the end,
the fuck praying,
you're making no sense.
Ain't gonna make me end this commercial.
If data is your strategy,
yes,
it's over.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
Use the code name,
Rogan and save yourself
10 percent off any.
The supplements.
The kettlebells had been selling like
crazy and the positive results that I'm
getting from people who really enjoyed
the workouts on twitter that are coming
in like crazy too.
I thank you very much.
I don't get behind anything unless
I 100 percent believe in it.
Even the flashlight,
if you want to beat off,
that's better.
Okay,
but with onnit.com,
everything we sell,
especially the supplements,
the first 30 pills,
there was a 100 percent
money back guarantee.
You don't have to return anything.
Just say this shit is not for
me and you get your money back.
We're that confident that one we're
selling you something that you're going to
enjoy and it's going to help you and to.
I don't want anybody to feel ripped off,
period.
I'm way more concerned about having people
feel like this is a even transaction
and this is a good deal for them
than I am about making money.
Use the codename Brogan.
Save 10 percent off any supplements.
Your last name,
I pronounce it coke cash,
right?
I don't want to fuck this up as
long as you don't say Kokesh.
I wouldn't say that to coke.
Coke,
coke,
cash is here.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Just fucking man.
We're going to get down
to the nitty gritty.
We're going to figure some shit out.
Maybe I'm not on a problem.
We will.
I am.
Okay.
He's promising.
Play the music.
No.
Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
Thank you fred.
During that commercial,
you know you were here for a very
emotional moment for us.
The last,
the flashlight.
I understand sir,
and I'm glad we got through that together.
I understand that deep
emotional connection you can
have with masturbatory aids.
Absolutely.
It's not that.
It's that they paid us that was deep
emotional and it's a solid product,
you know,
controversial but a solid product.
You can totally pull back
your microphone also.
It stretches out reaching.
Yeah.
That's part of what we're
kind of a street like
that.
A little bit underground tributing.
If I do it like a poignant moments,
people know.
Man,
that was a real microphone cord there.
You asked what was actually happening.
It's the cat clock.
You think they like to
count snowflake mentality.
You think people like the cat clock
really makes it sound less professional.
You know,
people think it's like a studio and stuff.
It's crazy like that.
Yeah,
but that clock does interrupt
your thought process for a second.
First second,
maybe not.
Maybe it makes you up to how retarded
you or you're fucking cat clock.
The clock me out every time the the,
our changes.
More twitter followers are
intuitive twitter than most
people have blocked does.
I didn't even know there was a catalog.
Yeah,
I think it's red bands.
Cat clock and it just,
it always is like,
it's always like,
Joe,
why are you so mean to me?
Or this is why I have
faith in the Internet.
Oh,
the Internet is the
ultimate balancing act,
isn't it?
Yeah.
That's how we met,
man.
Dude,
you have a hat with your own name on it.
I know it's kind of sticker with
your own name on it like you are.
You are 100 percent dedicated to you.
Yeah.
Well I,
I stopped short it wearing the t shirt
usually because that's a little creepy.
Is the t shirt and a hat together?
Oh yeah.
No,
that doesn't happen,
but dice clay was onstage at the Riviera
and Vegas this weekend and he had a
dice shirt on.
It was perfect and then
he sells that shirt.
It's just,
it just says dice and
the eye is like a dice,
you know,
like a dice cube.
So you were a good company with a hat,
with your name on it.
Thank you.
So,
um,
how long have you been doing this show,
Adam versus demand?
Well,
that's a good question because I got to
go way back to just even explain how I
started to stumble into this
now and explain to people
to explain to people what
your show is,
where people have never heard it's
Adam versus the [inaudible] dot com.
I do a daily podcast except when I'm,
when I'm traveling.
Like I haven't been so much recently but
I didn't want in Denver the other day,
but I normally do it out of my
apartment in northern Virginia.
So I'm inside the
beltway in Washington DC.
I feel like I'm dancing around the feet
of the Leviathan there and I'm able,
I'm able to poke the man.
I'm able to poke the machine there,
but I really,
I really hate living there.
It's,
it's really weird.
But I do my show out of my apartment
there and I do a youtube channel,
youtube.com/Adam,
Kokesh,
k o,
k e s h,
and I,
I just,
I,
none of what I do is work anymore.
I absolutely love it.
It.
And,
and I'm,
I'm obsessed with what I do.
I am absolutely committed and
driven and passionate about it.
I,
you know,
I have,
I have to smoke weed to
slow me down if anything,
but I always do my podcasts over every
morning and we post highlights from that
to youtube.
But I started my activism
way back in college.
Libertarians in,
in Claremont,
not too far from here,
uh,
was at Claremont Mckenna.
And I didn't,
I didn't really get it.
To me,
libertarian was,
well,
I'm not going to be a republican or
a Democrat because that Shit's lame,
you know,
that's just too obvious I'm going to be.
And yeah,
exactly an indie.
And it was kind of a way of,
of,
you know,
sticking it to the man to say,
yeah,
like down with your rules were
for drugs and prostitution.
And it was that sort of macho
flash libertarianism and
my story is really of the
deepening of my understanding
of the philosophy of this,
because I went to Iraq in
the middle of all this.
I was in Fallujah in 2004.
I was a reservist while I was going to
college and I've volunteered for what I
called my semester abroad and I did
seven months in Fallujah with the civil
affairs team.
I was in combat for most
of that time and it was.
It was a really intense experience and
coming home and watching the second
battle of Fallujah play out on the
front page of the New York Times.
While I knew that the only reason we
saw so many marines dying was because of
the political manipulations of what was
happening in the city over the summer
that I was there and I was there February,
September 2004.
And coming back and realizing that people
were dying for political bullshit was
a a significant turning point for me and
wanting to really figure out what was
behind this.
And this is the thing.
I think that sets Libertarians,
a partner that I think a lot of people
in my audience appreciate about your
perspective is that you ask why and
when you don't have good answers,
you reject the bullshit and the propaganda
and you see past it and you know,
your understanding of foreign policy
from that perspective is very appreciated
by a lot of veterans who have gone
through a similar experience that I have.
So I got back and I was active
with Iraq veterans against the war,
actually moved to DC to get a
masters in political management.
Oh actually I should say I actually,
I got in trouble for bringing a
pistol back from Iraq and it was,
it was a really nice one.
It was like engraved as a gift from
Saddam Hussein and have little gold plated
medallions on the pistol grip.
Yeah.
And I got in trouble for bringing them.
Well,
it's a long story,
but I had it on campus and my car got
stolen out of my car and instead of
letting it go,
I chased the guy down and there was a
campus security guy there and that's how I
got snagged for having an on campus and
it got confiscated and I tried to go.
I tried to go back to Iraq and this
is the thing that really the flip that
switch in your brain when you go through
bootcamp these days and you know,
they've heavily developed
the psychological process,
the conditioning that you go through to
make sure that you will obey orders and
you will pull the trigger.
And the reason I wanted to go back to
Iraq was because I didn't get a purple
heart the first time.
Like I hadn't.
I hadn't bled enough.
And it really is a sick thing and this
is what makes the military mentality
distinct.
There is nothing more glorious
than dying for your country.
And even patents said,
you know,
it's making the poor bastard die for his.
But in order to,
you know,
as part of the conditioning,
especially in the marines where there's
that certain machismo that first of
fight attitude and you know,
there's a noble intent behind it.
I wanted to have my life in
the line from my country,
but really for the people of America,
you know,
and that was why I enlisted
in the first place.
So they looked at it as what's the
best way to get people to listen to us?
What is the,
what's the best way to get people to do
the impossible to do the unthinkable.
He tell that that's what they're supposed
to do.
You have.
We have to figure out what the
best way to program them is.
And they figured it
out and they nailed it.
They got an account that pride that,
that fucking that is spreading her.
Yeah.
That feeling,
they put them in the,
just the,
the,
the training sequences and formula.
Just,
you know,
it's,
it's not just that,
because the lesson to be
learned here is that it's,
it's everybody.
Everybody who waves the American flag or
the nationalism that's imbued in all of
us.
It's the same thing to a lesser degree,
but it's still a perversion of humanity.
It's still a perversion of the way
human beings are designed to get along.
Right.
Great.
I think the idea of being an
American should be an ideal.
It should be an idea that we
have in our head and should be.
We should look at being American
as something we should aspire to,
but the idea that somehow or another
we're against them or they're against us.
Like what the fuck are you talking
about it and we don't even know them.
Yeah,
and it's not.
It's not about the arbitrary lines set
up by government around us or it's the
American heritage,
the American traditional moving towards
greater freedom and the stuff that that
represented.
The whole revolutionary war is a step
forward in and the human understanding of
liberty,
but you know,
it's,
it's an idea that's global.
It's essential to the
human nature does it,
and now we see that America as defined
by any specific thing other than that is,
let's be honest.
Kind of fucking disgusting.
Yeah,
exactly.
Scary and America should
be what we can contribute.
You know what,
what,
what is our potential or potential
to contribute is so much greater.
You know,
America is not the military
industrial complex.
America is the best fucking
music that's ever been created.
America's the best movies
that's ever been created.
The most creativity,
the most designed,
most,
all that shit.
I mean,
I love my friends in Europe.
I love the Japanese is not.
I'm not saying that I did any of this.
I'm not taking any credit for this.
I'm a fucking idiot.
I've never invented shit in my life,
but if I look at it objectively,
even if I lived in Spain,
I would tell you this,
I'd be like,
look at this freak motherfucker country
that in 200 years exploded onto the map,
covered the grove,
the globe with weapons
controlled the whole thing,
locked it all down.
Started boards like,
oh,
what a crazy little country you guys got,
and then got really fat and stupid.
Yeah,
it's fat and lazy and a lot of ways,
a lot,
a lot of dumb shit going on.
Well,
let's just corruption.
You can't maintain a steady ship
with a constant flow of corruption.
Eventually it just goes off the rails,
so eventually you just,
it's not going to balance out,
you're not,
you're not being honest about
how you're running things.
So,
so thing is disgusting.
Like it's not like,
like there was a threat
that we needed to go after,
don't you?
You guys are creating problems so
you can capitalize on resources.
Like it couldn't be any more obvious
kind of the definition of government
though.
But it's the scariest thing ever that
most people would never believe that if
you told them that,
they would say that is hippie bullshit.
That is nonsense.
Who the fuck do you think
you are to think like that?
You know,
what kind of a person are you?
This is America.
Well,
you know,
you said it in you.
I listened to your podcast with
Georgiou sucralose and you said,
you know,
with aliens,
like everybody's looking
for a daddy and it's this.
It's this manifestation of that
psychological desire to be taken care of.
And it was worse is with
government for a lot of it.
You said it was aliens and it was God
and religion and I don't know what else.
You said a couple of other things,
but you didn't say it was.
It was.
It was government.
You know,
and that's,
that's,
that's the big one.
And that's what's,
that's the global paradigm.
That's like the phase of evolution that
we're at in humanity that we're seeing
the institutionalization,
institutionalization will
collapse of when we see,
you know,
this is all centered around the scam of,
of the central banks,
of the Fiat currency because
that's how they really rip us off.
Everything else is about control,
but that's the real incentive.
It's all about exploitation.
That's,
I mean,
that's,
that's what motivates everything.
As a motivates government.
The banking system is
so confusing for people.
When you say the banking system,
it's like you might as well just be
making some noises with your mouth.
Nobody really even understands
what the fuck is going on.
It's propaganda and it's designed to make
you confused and when you look at how
much money they have,
when you go,
wait a minute,
wait,
what is that exactly?
Because are you,
what the fuck do you do that?
You get all these ones and Zeros.
Where's it all coming from?
How do you work with.
Here's why they don't teach
economics in high school though.
I mean because the basic concepts that
anybody can understand what have you very
easily come to the conclusion
with a very sound basis of,
of rationale and understanding of economic
framework to get to the point where
you can.
No really,
really no,
we're getting fucked.
That like all of the exponential increases
in productivity that should lead to
an increase in quality
of life for everybody.
It's still going up and we still see it,
you know,
the fact that we have smartphones
and computers and all this shit,
you know,
and,
and that the average American
is so much better off.
That's still an exponential growth.
But what it would really be if you didn't
have everybody who's on the teat of
government sucking all this
wealth away would have us,
you know,
in,
in flying cars by now.
I mean,
I know that sounds crazy,
but you see the wealth that's being
sucked away and what the implication is of
that,
we are getting fucked and what's worse
is that we're institutionalizing a system
that is not just a
system that robs from us,
but that kills people.
You know,
that's the police state,
the,
the military industrial complex.
You know,
the spasms of,
of statism,
of our.
But what government fundamentally is,
is the institutionalization of all of
our desires to control and dominate and
manipulate others by force.
It's pathological behavior.
It's pathological.
It's based on fear.
It's based on putting fear into its
citizens and being afraid of the other
people in the world that
other people are not us.
And you know,
until we figure out a way
to treat everyone that we
meet in this life as if it
was you living another life and told
the world can adopt and develop that
attitude.
We're always going to have clients that
are gonna lead us against other cons.
I mean,
that's just the way it is.
We are flawed,
fucked up species and somehow or another
we still have the echoes and remanence
of the bygone sword
fights in our fucking DNA,
you know,
that shit's still rattles around inside
our head and at the highest levels of
government.
They're willing to sacrifice lives
for money at a drop of a hat.
They're not worried about it at all
and they're going to go and clean up
afterwards and make money on that as well.
Oh yeah.
I mean it's,
it's a staggering business that's
based on 100 percent horseshit.
The idea that no one went to jail after
that whole weapons of mass destruction
thing and in Iraq,
the fact that none of those cuts went
to jail for lying about weapons of mass
destruction.
Being in Iraq,
just that alone,
it just shows you like,
what the fuck did you do?
Like what did you.
How do you not go to jail for that?
If you can't go to jail for that,
how are you trying to pretend
that this is a just system?
You guys made some shit up about weapons
of mass destruction purposely to get
people to go to war and then a million
people are dead now and you don't think
you fucked up.
You think that was the smart move.
Whoa.
But you know,
you know why that's possible?
Because the people that supported it
would rather live with that cognitive
dissonance than face up to the truth.
Yeah.
I guess it's also just,
it's harder because we have such a
psychological investment in America,
you know,
in our national,
we're Americans,
you know,
like that is who we are and,
and,
and it's like,
no,
you're a human being.
You have to,
you have to see past that.
But when you meet Nice people from
other countries and you're like,
poor fuck though,
he's Canadian,
be American.
You know,
people think like that.
you meet someone in Norway,
man,
poor guy born in Norway and shit.
What a great time.
You know,
we have a very distinct and intense form
of nationalism because we're such a war
culture.
I mean,
we don't want to think
of ourselves as that.
I would like to think of
ourselves as educated,
enlightened people,
but as a collective,
if we really are accepting the
fact that we move as a group,
Dan,
we're doing some shitty things.
You know what though?
No one I don't think
anyone is thinking about.
Honestly.
Even that's the thing.
They're not even looking at everybody
who's looking at it like you are,
you know,
with an honest.
I can see through all
that and it's the result.
It's the result of people not even think
is as soon as you think on that level,
you want to change it and really that's,
that's what,
that's what this,
this movement that,
that we think of ourselves
right now is a part of the,
the level Lucian.
That's really our objective.
Do you think that in the past they were
able to get things off much easier so
they have this sort of pattern of behavior
and the way they do business as far
as how we go to war,
like the Gulf of Tonkin type shit where
they could get away with stuff like that
in the past.
But today with the,
like the sort of the same
group are basically in charge.
I mean they've evolved somewhat,
but I mean there's photos of Rumsfeld,
shaking hands with Saddam was saying,
you know what I mean,
a long time ago when it was
the Reagan administration,
is that what it was from?
It was during the Iran,
Iraq war.
We're supporting Iran.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I mean,
we,
excuse me.
You know
what I gotta I gotTa stop myself there.
See,
that's how fucked up this is.
This is how ingrained
it is in the paradigm.
And you know,
even when I'm talking about the worst
fucking shit that government does,
the most offensive shit I and I,
I,
you know,
I cuss on my show and I get shit for it,
for my audience sometimes,
but I sat there all silly.
I'm going to,
I'm going to have,
I'm going to have a curse jars.
I'm going to put a curse jar.
And every time,
every time I use status,
collectivist language,
every time I say to refer to myself as
part of the evil federal government that
committed these crimes,
I'm going to punish myself by
putting a quarter in the real curse.
Sounds like something John Heifer do
the ladder at the top of the ladder.
It really is a bunch of old
white dudes with war money.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
Like when you look at the
people that run Halliburton,
you look at Dick Cheney and look at,
you know,
this old white dudes with war money.
I mean they're in the business of war.
Really the percentage of the income that,
how Burton per,
how much they profit off of war.
That's a staggering number.
As disgusting as that warm
money is for Halliburton,
what it's really about
as the bankster money,
it's about the money that goes through
the financial system that flows faster
for war.
But,
but you know what this I have,
I.
let me,
let me tell you my,
my long view perspective here because
I'm much more optimistic and I,
you know,
when you understand government
to be pathological behavior,
it's our inner.
Whenever you say we need
government for something,
you're saying we can't
solve this peacefully.
We need to somehow as the majority impose
our will on the minority or we need to
take money from people by force because
they're not charitable enough or you
know,
they don't care about their own
defense and for whatever it is,
we can't do it peacefully.
We know we need,
we need force,
we need,
we need coercion and it really
comes out of the monkey brain.
It comes out of that.
When we evolved in the state of nature,
it was in our best interest
that whoever was the biggest,
you know,
whoever could pick up the biggest rock
was in charge and you go along to get
along.
Otherwise you don't eat tonight.
And we're evolving past that.
And as we just,
as we develop greater technological
dominance over our environment,
as we are better able
to process information,
all of these things are leading to the
evolution towards a stateless society.
We are evolving past this phase of statism
and like you were saying about what
they get away with in war
to answer your question,
you know,
it,
they get away with less.
It's harder to come up with an excuse.
I mean look at now and it's really sad
to see that we're marching toward Iran.
But I've made the prediction for awhile
now that we'd see boots on the ground in
Syria first because it's
much better propaganda to
have a humanitarian war where
we can save a bunch of people
from an evil dictator than,
well,
it's the clash of nations and we're
trying to keep Iran from arming themselves
and that,
that propaganda is kind of wearing thin.
But it's scary.
And I will see they
might get away with that.
They might get a war in Iran and it's all.
Absolutely.
I mean it,
it.
But,
but it's in the 21st century with the
historical perspective that we have.
Is Warren just not fucking
embarrassing at this point.
It should be,
you know,
it's fascinating me.
Is this thing that's going
on in Pakistan,
if that isn't racist,
I don't know.
What is this flying of drones that
shoot missiles and blow up citizen.
It's cowardly.
Obama's a fucking murderer.
It's ridiculous.
The idea that we just accepted.
I look,
I believe you that there's some bad
Taliban guys out there that want to commit
terrible things and we
need to get to them,
but you need to be a little
bit more accurate bitch.
You imagine if they were using
those things in Germany or you know,
or Japan or anywhere that
we're allies with and you know,
and it caused this kind of damage.
But the fact that it's
happening in Pakistan,
like,
oh,
it's brown people on the planet.
Yeah.
What do they doing?
They love their.
Lost a donkey,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
these poor folks,
they're looking at them like they're,
you know,
they're living a shit life anyway.
Well,
you know,
it's one of the things that
they have done recently in,
uh,
with the Taliban.
They've said that they're going to stop
administering polio vaccines if they
don't stop the drone strikes because
the ptsd that they are causing in the
population is worse than
having fucking polio.
I mean,
how citizens.
But I got a quote here.
This is Anwar Allah,
lucky the New Mexico born a man that was
killed in Yemen by a drone strike by,
by order,
by Obama.
His 16 year old son was also murdered.
Uh,
the same way a week later you probably
heard that story of Abdul Ramond all
lucky and he was,
he was made out to be the great
propagandist for al Qaeda.
This is,
this is the quote from him.
Our position needs to be reiterated
and needs to be very clear.
The fact that the US has administered
that death and homicide of over 1 million
civilians in Iraq.
The fact that the United
States is supporting the
deaths of killing of thousands
of Palestinians does not
justify the killing of one
US civilian in New York City
or Washington DC.
And the deaths of 6,000 civilians in New
York and Washington DC does not justify
the death of one civilian and Afghanistan.
That doesn't sound like a terrorist.
It sounds like the guys making sense.
No Shit.
That's why I'm kind of afraid to
be in this line of work myself.
Yeah.
It's creepy line of work
when they can just label you,
you know?
I mean,
no one wants to look at it from this
side that perhaps the United States has
done some heinous things.
There's a reason why these people want
to do something to us and we go us to,
to the citizens of this great nation.
You know what?
In a way,
they're smarter than us because our
reaction culturally is dehumanization.
It's,
it's an implicit racism for us.
They're smarter than they want it.
When they actually come
at it strategically,
like they want to change our behavior,
they want us to stop bombing them.
You know?
And maybe they're not good.
I'm not endorsing terrorism obviously.
But if anything,
their anger is much more aware
and directed at the US government.
Well,
my whole positions that were not innocent,
you know,
the,
the United States government,
we,
it,
whatever's over there,
we're not as innocent.
It's that simple.
So if we're not innocent,
we have to take some sort
of responsibility where they
have to take some sort of
responsibility for the repercussions.
If you're doing that's fucked up and
people are dying,
you got to know that you've,
you've done something terrible
and you need to make amends,
you know,
you need to fix this whole thing.
Like you can't just to
get out of there now.
He can't just get out of there and leave
it behind some fucking crazy civil war.
Well that's the denial that
America is in and if I may,
the next part of my story was coming
back from Iraq and in trouble with this,
trying to go back to get a purple heart.
And when I got out of the Marines I had
been as a sergeant who spoke Arabic,
was civil affairs experience.
Pissed off because I was managing a
barracks and mowing lawns for most of the
year.
And I got out and I was disgruntled.
It was like the day after I got a medal
for heroism under fire and all the other
crap that I got cited for
when I was in Fallujah.
That took three years to process.
They busted me down from sergeant
corporal and I got out and I was in my,
you know,
the exploration of my.
Do they do that from
bringing the pistol back?
Oh,
because if it got through the system
and got back to NCI and Yada Yada,
Yada.
So I got in trouble for that.
So you never got that pistol back?
No,
I know.
And,
but I did get to fire
it a couple of times.
Pistol.
Well an official gift from the
regime or something like that.
But it was the coolest orical piece I got.
I got plenty of guns now.
But this is an important thing about
who is going to be on the front lines of
this revolution right now.
They were facing who was going to help
us evolve past this status paradigm.
Who's going to help us push past and see
past the collapse of government because
it's not going to be the people that the
system treats well and this whole thing
is set up.
You have the propagandizing class,
you know,
you,
you have the dependent class,
you have the enforcement class and the
law enforcement in the military and you
have people that are bought
into the system as a whole,
you know,
whole variety of levels in a way.
That's how they get away with is
they make everybody think they're,
they're benefiting from it.
And they have people you know.
And it's like if capitalism,
a true free market,
unnatural society where
people have property rights
is like a rough fabric when
you,
when you introduced the Federal Reserve
and you have this thing that can create
money out of thin air,
it's like pulling it up and create an
unnatural spike and concentration of
wealth and power.
And we have this illusion of capitalism.
Like we can own property and we can trade,
but it's this whole
spike where everybody is,
you know,
kind of picked up along with it.
And this illusion of being able to print
money that's worth something and that's
how they manipulate the economy and
that's what people really get screwed.
But the first people that are going to
be questioning the system aren't going to
be the guy that was student body president
or captain of the football squad or
the cheerleading team,
you know,
it's going to be the miscreants and
the punks and the and the misfits.
And the people that were,
you know,
in a sense challenging authority naturally
because they had something in it or
they had something in their life.
And the thing is right now it's
about being a victim of government.
You know,
how many people do you know
that that got arrested?
And when they got arrested they,
they,
they turned political.
You know,
they started paying attention because
it hits home and they stopped trusting
government.
And that's a really important thing.
And the rest of us have to
stop turning a blind eye.
And I say,
the rest of us,
again,
maybe a bad collectivizing term,
but the people that are asleep to this
need to stop turning a blind eye and
saying,
well,
I got mine.
I'm cool.
I got my paycheck because
somebody else was getting fucked.
And the thing is that it's so exciting
is that enough people have been fucked.
Now that it's coming to a critical
mass where people are questioning the
government,
people are waking up,
people are saying we don't
need this thing anymore.
We are standing up to the bully.
And that's what's so fun about,
you know,
what I do now in civil disobedience.
Speaking of which did,
did you get my invitation
to the party yesterday?
Okay,
well we had a really exciting event
and this is a civil disobedience beach
party.
We went to like a beach party.
We went to the.
Yeah,
I know in a sense,
but oh man,
we know it's,
it's,
it's where you deliberately go and
break as many laws nonviolently as you
possibly can.
And so we dug holes deep,
deeper than 18 inches and we smoked pot
without a license and we threw footballs
and frisbees and it not allowed to throw
footballs and Frisbees at the Santa
Monica Pier.
What?
Yeah.
Oh,
come on.
Really?
No frisbees.
Yeah.
But see,
you know,
what's your,
what's your normal reaction to that?
Ah,
fuck it.
What's another law?
And you walk away and he's so stupid.
So you know,
people are.
And this is really petty.
Well the real problem is country kids
that throw those fucking frisbees too hard
and they hit babies.
So the answer is to have police go and
try to chase them down and issue them
thousand dollars ticket.
So the answer is you got to go back in
time to when their parents aren't seeing
them and then work with the parents.
Try to straighten out with their emotional
bullshit to make them a shitty parent
so that they can deliver a kid
that's better functioning in society.
Okay?
So let me know.
That kid is all fucked up.
You got to deal with them.
Somebody made a fucked up kid,
lit that fucked up kid.
Get loose and he's whipping a frisbee
around near your two year old baby.
Okay,
but this is why things are getting better.
This is,
this is the site because people want
to be better parents and pathological
behavior.
Why do people grow up
to be violent criminals?
It's usually because they were
abused as children in some way.
You're right.
Yeah.
It's,
it's emotional abuse or physical abuse,
but people aren't naturally violent.
People are.
The natural state is to want to
cooperate with fellow human beings.
At least that's what we're evolving
towards and so think about it.
Like right now,
compared to the state of
nature 200,000 years ago,
you know,
everybody had to work 16 hours a day
hunting and gathering to survive,
right?
And now the average American can
work from when they're 22 to 65,
eight hours a day with
weekends and vacation time
and support a whole family for
their lifetime on that.
And if anything,
it would be a lot less than that with,
with without the central banking system
that we have today without the systems
of government exploitation,
robbing that exponential growth,
what should be exponential growth
and quality of life and it's,
it's still exponential,
but not nearly as much as it should be
and what we're coming to like how are you
going to convince people that you need a
welfare state when you can work for one
year and save enough money to live at
the quality of life that we enjoy today
for the rest of your life.
That's
and,
and to me,
that's what makes this such
an exciting time to be alive.
And you just look at,
look at how much less violence there is
and this is a really beautiful thing.
You can look at government and
be pissed off all you want.
And this is where I've come to now,
hour as a zen libertarian is
being able to see this big,
bigger picture and that the actual average
amount of violence that an individual
is subject to is at an all time historic
low for as long as we've been able to
track it.
That's part of that evolution.
This is the natural development of
life from single celled organisms,
from you know,
little molecules bouncing around
in the primordial soup together.
The essence of life is cooperation
is pooling of resources you know,
of coming together of
energy coming into harmony.
And that's what we're going through.
And we're seeing this
process of two steps forward.
One step backwards,
and we're in the middle of a
big step backwards right now.
That really is centered around
the institutionalization
of the Federal Reserve
and the modern systems of government
going back about 100 years.
And within that time,
you know,
we've had steps forwards,
gay rights movement,
the women's rights movement,
the civil rights movement.
Not In how they were
institutionalized in government,
but how they,
what they represented for society.
We're steps forward,
but we're coming to this major step
forward now when we get past this entire
paradigm of statism and it's a beautiful
thing to see that as we're able to
raise our children nonviolently as we're
able to be better parents because we
have better prosperity and
better just the leisure time,
the ability to do things that
the cave men couldn't do,
and raise children that are emotionally
well balanced and don't engage in this
pathological behavior that has government.
I,
uh,
I agree that it seems that if you,
you know,
you,
you measure our time on earth in
comparison to the Greeks or the Romans or
anybody lived in any sort of
an ancient civilization like,
yeah,
no one's ever had it as good as we
have as far as the less violence,
the more health,
the more pleasure.
It's like the people
being nice to each other.
People understanding the impact
of being nice to each other.
Actually understanding
what that's all about now.
That's never happened before.
But the way it's happening now,
Americans are factors were
like citizens of the empire,
but the.
Yeah,
but if you look at the
rest of the world though,
if you look at especially the impact on
some of the things that are necessary in
order to produce the amount of power
that's necessary to run this crazy sort of
a peaceful,
easy go and country that we think
of as America or you drive around,
there's really not that
much crime drive around.
It's really not that much violence.
Well,
how,
how were you driving on gas?
Where's that gas coming from?
Dude,
the gas is coming from a place that's
getting bombed from the sky with missiles
and that's where we have
apartment buildings or blowing up.
I mean,
you know.
Yeah.
People are dying left and right,
so it's.
So.
It's.
Is it possible to have all that
shit without all the bad shit?
Is it even possible to have in this day
and age or is this like an over clock
society,
is the only way to have a society
like America possible is they're at
the very top of the food chain doing all
sorts of fucked up on ethical shit or
is it possible to have the control over
the resources that we have and still be
ethical as it possible to run a society
like this and not do anything fucked up?
I think even the way that you're asking
that question is reinforcing the idea of
a country and I am right.
Anything that's going to
eventually completely go away.
Well,
no.
Yes,
but it,
it,
it represents the framework
from which you're coming from.
This represents the status paradigm of,
uh,
you know,
how do we have an identity or how do
we have a society when you're using
government in,
in a way that doesn't clearly define it,
and when you really break it down,
the only clear way to define government
is a group of people within arbitrary,
geographically based monopoly
on the initiation of force.
That's,
that's what sets them apart.
Like if I go in and say,
you know,
put a gun to your head and say,
give me your wallet,
I can't,
you know,
that that's wrong,
or you can't be a gang member.
But if you're in a war
with another gang and say,
look,
these guys aren't murderers.
I,
they're,
they're in my army.
I made them go to war with the bad gang.
Exactly what the fuck you talking about?
That's it.
I mean generally police,
you know,
and it's,
it's what's sick is that
we have to extricate,
we have to,
we have to pull out these
legitimate functions of
government in order to get rid
of it.
Like it's really tricky
with the police state.
It's an issue I'm really passionate about.
You know,
one of the things that I'm kind of put
me on the map was the Jefferson dance
party wouldn't when I got picked up
and body slammed by a police officer,
the Jefferson Memorial
for dancing in public.
And that was,
that was,
uh,
that's my video.
That's got over a million views.
Police pull that shit up.
Brian.
Where's Brian?
But he's Outta here.
You can't get it from the sound anyways,
but vanished.
You know,
police officers do serve
a legitimate function.
The problem is that they've got
a government monopoly on it,
you know,
that they provide for the public safety.
But private security is obviously much
better and when you have this monopoly
power,
they're not accountable to the people.
There's always that detachment and it's,
it's the,
the idea of government.
You say,
do we need government for society?
It's a government is
antithetical to society.
If Society is defined as how people come
up with an identity and come together
peacefully and cooperatively and engage
in commerce and do productive things.
And it's like,
you know how,
how do you say,
how do you live healthy with
a giant Leech on your back?
You know,
is that essential?
And it's like,
no,
you're in this government
has to be a leach.
That's the question.
Is government have to be that?
Is it possible to have a
government where it's just,
you know,
we have a set of values that we put in
place in order to help society run better
and that's we all take place in it and
we call that government could be not
elite,
but it can never by definition be moral
and will always then give someone an
unjust power that is corrupting.
I got to see this video,
man.
Brian,
where's Brian?
You'll want me to vamp
Brian.
All right.
This is Adam [inaudible] taking over
the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
Thank you very much.
Hm.
Dustin,
Dustin is here.
Mild coproducer from the radio show.
They want to send them a text
message to them to get back in there.
So explain to me what happened to you.
They picked you up and body slammed you.
Well,
it's,
Oh,
did you want to see a video?
Man?
I don't want to see in it
now.
So it's a bit of a story as it goes back,
like three or four years ago,
there was a group of 18 people that were
just a bunch of Libertarian activist
that like Thomas Jefferson.
And so they wanted to go dance
because he was the dancing president.
I didn't find out about this
until after the incident.
My facebook wall got just covered with
all these Jefferson quotes about how he
liked to dance and bust out the fiddle
at the White House and stuff like that.
But they went and danced at midnight on
Thomas Jefferson's birthday just as a
little flash mob thing.
Right.
And the security guards came and start
trying try to shoo them out of the
memorial.
And one of them was dancing
out and got arrested.
And they were like,
what the fuck?
And so they tried to to fight it in court.
And like three years later the judge said,
you know,
like as if the,
if the judge had said on the grounds
of it's improper usage or it's a safety
threat or it's like,
you know,
the,
there was a way that they could have
legitimately said there's no dancing.
But it's kind of a ridiculous thing to
say anywhere that you're legally allowed
to be.
You don't have control over your body.
Or if you move in a certain way,
like that's going to be illegal,
you know,
so it's,
it's kind of absurd on its premise,
like most of the things of,
of,
of government when you really go down
to the actual core premise of what it
means to be,
what,
when,
when you say there should be a law for
this or it should be illegal for that,
but we,
uh,
we decided to go back because the judge
said it was not appropriately reverent
enough.
Reverent,
yes.
You had to be reverent
of Thomas Jefferson.
This is a public memorial where you've
got kids spilling drinks and playing with
toys and cars and shit like all
over the place and you can't dance.
What's the video?
If you go to youtube.com/Adam kochish
and then search for most viewed
a high vitamin K o k
e s h o k what was it?
K O k e s h,
yes.
It's kind of a long video.
It's 10 minutes.
But so we went back and we know,
we decided we're going to start dancing
and the cops were waiting for us.
So they said who's in charge here?
And we all pointed to Thomas Jefferson,
you know,
the giant 30 foot statue of him and
this couple that was there just started
dancing and they bumped into one of the
cops and the cop was like pointing his
goons.
You go go,
go arrest them.
And they're swaying like hugging
like Dan the barely dancing.
And so the rest of us were like,
well fuck that.
It's on.
And I was listening to what you can do
it by ice cube and you could barely call
what I was doing dancing.
But by the end of this they,
they picked me,
the cop like picked me up and body
slammed me because I was resisting with my
hands out like this at my
hands out in front of me.
Like,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not violent.
And he picked me up and body slammed me
and then kneed me in the ribs and choked
me on the ground there.
And the crazy part is,
you know,
I was in the marines,
I was,
I was in the Marine Corps rugby team.
We trained for MMA right now.
But if I'm,
I didn't know how to fall,
like I,
W I would have fractured my skull,
like if I had gone limp and flipped
bags on a marble floor and I would have
cracked my skull open,
but you could have done,
um,
I,
you know,
ask around and I was okay.
We did.
It's the top in the middle there.
You can watch the whole thing unfold.
Somebody that's leading
this guy body slammed you.
This is the.
Yeah,
I mean it's this,
it's this little chubby guy with,
with probably a really small penis,
but that's,
that's the people that are authorized
to use violence by government.
That's got a sweet bike helmet.
So he comes up and he's threatening to
arrest us without telling us that there's
any law that we would be violating the
city to allow citation
and he just avoids the question.
You'll find out what,
what am I being arrested for?
You'll find out he's incompetent.
Then
we tried to get a legal
definition of dancing.
Wow.
What if you're at a time when you making
movements with your body still dancing?
Yeah.
So now he calls over his gun and he's
look at the little finger poke,
come on,
stop dancing.
Oh my God,
this is crazy.
This is nothing man.
This is,
this is just the beginning of this.
Give me a warning.
And these cops are
arresting her for dancing,
for standing in slang.
You know,
it's funny because this
happened in New York,
so there's me sort of dancing.
This is crazy.
So this is what we do now.
Regular civil disobedience
where we just risked,
arrest and stand up to the
bully that has government.
You know,
we had the curse in Middleborough
Massachusetts last week.
Wow.
This is crazy.
They made it illegal to curse.
Did you hear that story?
I was in Middleborough,
Massachusetts back and had a protest.
Instead.
We're just free fucking
speech demonstration
so it wouldn't be complete with
little stare down with the cops there.
And I really didn't think I was going to
go out and get arrested late actually.
I thought saying what
does this dude saying?
You hate America.
You hate freedom.
We've seen that to the cop.
Yup.
So this is where it starts to get ugly.
So he's like reaching out and
punching him in the chest.
This is America,
the public.
So this is the crazy part here.
See there,
he needs me in the ribs and you
see it go in like resisting arrest.
Still resisting arrest.
I mean even though it is as stupid
as it is of what the charge is,
and then I mean when a police officers.
But that's the point is to
show the violence of it.
There's no,
there's no justification for that.
The whole thing is ridiculous.
Let's cops.
They wanted to maintain this bullshit.
Yeah.
Bullshit.
Sense of control and authority and they
didn't recognize something that was
absolutely not a threat.
Just a bunch of peaceful people.
Oh,
they're hugging and you got to arrest
him for hugging and moving their bodies.
That's.
There's no,
there's no justification for this.
This is nonsense.
You guys weren't causing
problems or hassling people mean.
If you look into the
context of this video,
this is insane.
I don't know how these guys cannot.
You cannot.
You cannot stop them from dancing.
You cannot stop them from kissing.
You cannot stop doing.
Then they kicked the media out,
like how perfect is this as as
a microcosm of what government.
Who's got this camera?
Who's filming this?
This is actually dustin.
Actually the guy in the room right now.
This was when I had my tv show in DC.
What is he filming this with?
Dustin,
you want to step in here?
What are we filming?
I can't hear you.
Just a little camera.
I think he said it's a
small handheld camera.
Was a canon from back.
Nobody told you to stop filming.
It was funny because they kick out
the mainstream guy before they see me.
I was kind of just dancing along,
come and moving the laser,
so there's a couple other guys that were
filming this as well to get kicked out.
What's really ironic is they kicked out.
Well it doesn't say they
kicked out the guy from Fox.
There's a local Fox network,
I think that was covering it
that day and they kicked him out.
They kick out the guy with the
big camera and then Dustin,
because you know he's.
Wow.
We were shoestring television.
What?
That right there was
just idiots with power.
That's all.
That was.
Incompetent fools.
That's a foolish person.
It isn't that a fun way to wake people
up to to show people that he's a pussy.
This is what I always say about any,
any laws,
any people getting arrested.
I use what I call the
clinics would method.
Could you imagine clinics
would in a movie holding a gun,
arresting someone for that?
If not,
then it's a stupid law because if you're
not stealing or hurting someone or
robbing someone within.
What's the smart law?
Joe?
A smart law is something
that's set in place.
People don't fuck five-year-olds.
Maybe that should be a law.
Maybe the earlier that we should have
or are the ones that are based on on
respecting each other instead
of having a central authority,
deciding what what even the
standards of society are going to be.
Do you think that with the Internet
and what's happening now with the
integration of society and technology
that we're sort of slowly but surely
getting closer to each other,
even that it's comfortable and it's
going to get to a certain point in time
where there's not going to be a
whole lot of privacy in this world?
Yeah.
No,
but I think maybe that'll be.
I mean,
it's scary for us
because we value privacy,
but it might ultimately be for the best.
I think it's always for the best.
I have faith in technology
because it's empowering,
but it's kind of scary right now to
see that it's empowering to itself.
What I'm saying doesn't have a moral idea.
We have this idea that it's only for
good until ai comes live when when
artificial intelligence
actually becomes sent.
You know,
there's a lot of.
There's a lot of scientists,
very intelligent people that have
studied this shit their whole life.
That guy in that movie,
the singularity movie was
Kurzweil's documentary.
Was it called transcendent?
Transcendent man.
There's a guy in England is terrified
of what he calls artilects artificial
intellects.
He's terrified of the possibility
of them actually getting to a point
technologically where they can think
for themselves and shut things off and
create new ones and create
new artificial intelligence.
It's more powerful and with
more potential than they have,
but this is all real.
Very,
very possible.
You can't say no like this
is 100 percent possible.
It's scary.
No,
it's no.
It's not.
So technology is available.
Yeah,
but it's not always good for this.
I mean,
it's good.
It is what the universe is,
which is ever complex.
Just complexification on top
of complexification keeps
moving in that direction.
It doesn't stop,
you know,
stars explode and they eventually
become fucking human beings.
I mean,
all of this is coming from this idea
that things get more and more complex and
more and more crazy,
but might not necessarily
be good for humans.
Technology might be terrible for humans.
We might just be the
rats that build the raft.
Well might just be the monkeys
that start the computer life form.
They start the artificial ones and
zero life on and we say it's not real,
but it becomes real when you make it real.
If artificial intelligence actually
becomes sentience than it is real.
That's a real life form and we just
don't think of it and respect it like,
oh,
like we would in alien life form because
we think of it as something that we
have control over because
we just shut the power off.
We just turn the switches on for now.
That's all true at some
point that goes away.
But yeah,
if you give that the computer program
that you create the initiative to act on
its own and it's much more intelligent
than you are that things might get crazy.
Oh No,
they are going to get crazy,
but that's not good.
It's not good for us.
Well,
I don't think that's going to be
good for all the dumb fucks that.
Yeah,
but then you're like the person
with the rotary telephone saying,
oh,
those cell phones,
they're crazy.
They're bad for you.
Well,
yes,
to a certain extent.
You know,
if you talk to people that
live in the mountains,
they still stand by that shit.
You're fucking yourself up with all those
cell phone signals and you don't need
to check your email every five minutes,
but you know,
this when we might be is
just a step along the way.
I mean,
me surely are right.
we look at evolution.
We look at these new fossils they just
discovered today where there was a,
or it was just a news release today about,
uh,
some,
some hominoid that was a distant relative
of ours that was upright and walking 6
million years ago.
It was pretty radical discovery.
They're figuring this out.
Just think of that.
Six million years ago there
was some fucking monkey thing,
and then 6 million years later,
boom,
unr sitting in front of giant laptops
and ones and Zeros are flying around,
know,
through these pipes and wires
and shit under the ocean.
And whoa,
it's getting fast.
Yeah.
It's always getting faster
and faster and faster.
You know what?
That's what tempts me to be scared,
should be,
is that we're going to get to this point.
We're going to the technological
singularity coming in what 20 years we,
and this is the implication of that when
we have a computer that's smarter than
the human brain and in a sense we've,
that's like an arbitrary benchmark,
you know,
a more significant benchmark.
That in a way is not a benchmark
because as soon as we have,
you know,
the wheel,
we're able to use that to get rate,
get more technology,
you know,
every innovation builds on
the previous innovations.
But in a sense we get to the point where
we have computers that we tell design
the next smarter computer design,
the next Margaret computer chip and we're
already kind of at that point and then
it takes off this exponential curve.
Next thing you know,
we're,
we're telling computers how to solve,
instructing these things to solve
and they're going to tell us gay shit
together,
bitch.
You know,
what I'm scared of is that like right
now we see in the news they have this
laser that can hit your scan and do a
molecular analysis from 100 feet away and
the Tsa is going to have this and be
able to tell what bowl breakfast that
morning.
It's crazy,
but it scares me to see that
that's in the government's hands.
But at the same time I'm,
I'm so confident,
you know,
and like I said,
is going to get scary and at some point
every surface surrounding this is going
to be a touchscreen and you virtual
reality merges with reality and then who
knows,
but now we're going to have to jump ahead
and started talking about my last dmt
experience because it
really relates to that.
But what we're,
what we're coming to is there's going
to be a point where basically everybody
gets a therapy robot.
That's my prediction.
And in a way,
you know what I thought about this.
Every single trend that I look
at like way into the future.
Uh,
I go,
wait a second.
How is it already happening now?
And in a sense,
think about how much therapy and
psychological benefit people get from the
Internet.
The fact that they can
look shit up and go,
oh,
I know I have issues because of this.
Or they're able to find communities,
people that work through their issues in
a way it's able to develop issues more
likely than a KKK website.
I fucking sleep with a laptop in my bed.
That's the percentage of what's being
done on the Internet is not educational in
one way or another.
I mean the,
the,
the potential for education exists.
But compare what's happening majority
station with the Internet compared to what
happened.
Everything's accelerating,
whether it's entertainment or education.
Kids are smarter today.
They have more access
to information today,
less,
less viable to be sucked in by propaganda.
This,
this,
uh,
it's a different time.
We live in a time that's
just is unprecedented.
This is,
we're in the,
we're in the wild west.
We're in the wild west of technology.
Each time we look back in human history,
we're going to see this as the,
as the point at which we
hit the vertical asymptote.
That's what the next 20,
30 years it's going to be that curve and
the and the exponential growth curve.
That is the human experience.
I call it the roaring twenties
of the technological age.
That's what I take where we're at.
I think we're in the roaring twenties
of the technological age because I think
they're right now.
We still don't really have a handle on
what this fucking thinking that actually
do,
you know,
instilled.
There's all clunky things like
windows run time errors and you know,
hundreds of thousands
of computer viruses and.
But what's going,
what's going on with Brian has
to talk to the AC guy leaves.
I'm glad I dress for the warm weather.
Yeah.
We have some funky air conditioning
issues here at the ice house,
so we're trying to work out.
It's funny that you call it the ice
house and it's hot as fuck in here.
I went through that bad joke routine in
my head on the way over here today is
much better than yesterday though.
Yesterday was pretty brutal.
I don't know how people do Vegas,
man.
I don't think I could do 120
degrees that you step outside.
It's like getting hit in the face with
a hairdryer solution for seven months.
Man.
What's that like?
You don't notice over 1:15,
you just sort of like real and it's
the same way for like with me for weed,
you know,
you get so high and they kind of Plateau.
It's like above,
above about 115 degrees Fahrenheit.
The human body and the desert
can't really tell the difference.
There are times when you inhale fire,
you know,
from a hot breeze.
But really it's just,
you're just hot.
Were you over there without
Pat Tillman was killed.
He was in Afghanistan.
But when I.
Did you hear the news
when you were over there?
Uh,
you know what?
Because I remember that unfolding.
I was there in 2004.
You want me to look it up because I
wasn't always remember what you felt like
when you were heard.
Like all the shit that went down
when they tried to say it was,
he was killed in action and it
was really friendly back then.
I,
you know,
I was asleep,
I was,
I was one of the sheep.
Really.
I wasn't,
uh,
I wasn't politically attuned.
So when I heard the store and was like,
I acknowledged it,
but I wasn't really find that hard to
believe you're very articulate guy.
I mean,
he can't,
even if you're obsessed
with all this information,
there's no way that you would be
a stupid person when you're young
to believe in it.
And I,
you know,
you're susceptible.
We should step back and maybe
for a minute and talk about this,
this,
uh,
this podcast because there are a lot of
people and I want to get a shout out to
Michael Salvey for making it possible
for me to come out here because there are
a lot of people like him in my audience
that they really cared about me getting
to have a conversation with you.
And there are a,
you know,
in a way I really look
up to you and I feel like
as much as my audience wants you to
benefit from hearing my perspective right
now and talk about what I'm,
what,
what we refer to ourselves as awake to
our understanding of government society,
you know,
I want to,
uh,
you know,
you're,
you're 14 years ahead of me,
but you're like,
you know,
I want,
I want to,
I want to learn something from you
almost want to be interviewing you.
But I think we all were
learning from each other.
I mean,
you saying that you look up to me is,
it's always funny to me when people say
things like that because I think the
reality of it is we all inspire each
other and it's great when we run into
someone who we really feel
like is on the right path.
Like,
fuck man,
you're out there doing it,
you know,
and we benefit from each other.
All of us.
Do,
you know,
that's just,
that's,
that's the good thing about the internet.
That's a great thing about the end of the
Internet connect people like you and I
were in past years.
It would be so impossible.
This is that we exchanged
a couple series of tweets.
We don't even talk to each
other face to face too.
We're actually saying no,
I mean that's a,
that's a crazy,
crazy world.
So in that sense it does amazing things,
but we were all.
Everybody has a part in this thing is
one of the things I was going to say
earlier when you were,
um,
when,
when you were talking about people
and the human mind and the power of a
computer,
the crazy thing about people is not just
the power of the human mind is the fact
that we can figure out how
to work together because
the only way a computer gets
made is if somebody figures out how to
make all the different parts of it and
figure out how to integrate them
together and make it work together.
There's a lot.
That's a lot of motherfuckers.
That's not one dude figuring out how to
Code Algorithms and figuring out how to
send packets or the Internet.
No,
this is like a bunch of people.
Everyone has a specific task
and guys like you have a task,
guys like me have a task.
We all have that
task is what?
What are you drawn towards?
And even if it's fucking
playing basketball,
if that's what you love to do,
and if you're fucking thinking
about basketball all the time,
your,
that's your thing,
man.
That's not a,
it's not a bad thing.
Standup comedy is a ridiculous pursuit.
You just making people laugh.
That's not still,
it's not a bad thing.
You in lane people and
your comedy sets you apart.
It's not enlightened.
It's,
I tell them shit that I heard you
share a very valuable and empowering
perspective.
Uh,
I'm happy that that's the case for me.
It was,
you know,
that that's true and I appreciate it.
I appreciate that.
That's the case for
your masturbation jokes,
you know,
in,
in today's repressed age are empowering
the people that are afraid to talk about
those things.
Well,
I think that,
you know,
the,
the lessons and the battles that you go
through in your life where you figure
out what stupid and what's empowering,
what's good and what's bad for you not
to have a perspective when you get to be
a certain age.
We hit 44 years old and not have some
shit figured out that you didn't have when
you were 25.
This is ridiculous.
But from,
for me,
it's like when whenever someone would
say they look up to me or you know,
hey man,
you changed my life.
I would say like I'm not going to antenna.
Okay.
I'm just antenna for all the
shit that's out there in,
in this crazy fucking weird world.
So when I repeat shit back or when I
analyze and add a bunch of shit together
that I've,
that I've read that other
people have figured out,
someone saying they look up to that.
It's a very weird thing
to hear because it's just,
I'm just just dealing the stuff,
you know,
just doing comedy or doing podcasts.
It's not a,
it doesn't ever seem like
a anything important,
but when you get the overwhelming amount
of response that this podcast gets on
twitter and you know,
and whatever,
anything on the Internet,
my master port,
it can fuck with your head.
It gets kinda tricky.
You feel like you got
this weird obligation,
you know enough people
come up to you and say,
the Ama changed my life.
You start going,
man,
maybe I should start a fucking cult.
Big Ass.
Maybe that's my move man.
Big Ass plot of land in Brazil somewhere.
Just tell everybody.
Well fuck this country.
Let's move man.
We could run shit.
Nice down there.
So the air conditioner,
the weather's beautiful.
The air conditioner outside is being
worked on and should be done in like 30
minutes.
So they're going to turn
it off for 30 minutes.
But when I walked out I was like,
so how long is it going to take?
And this is what I saw.
Look at that.
We'll watch this.
See right here.
He's got.
He do.
Don't put that on the Internet.
That's the guy that's told them.
You're going to put that
on the Internet please.
By the way,
we should tell the
federal federal rallies.
He is a licensed patient
here in California.
What do you think of that,
man?
That's a creepy thing.
When we had a Tommy Chong on,
we've talked about that.
We said it was basically a money grab.
These dea agents that are rating these
California dispensary's even though in
the California state law,
medical marijuana is legal,
there are allowed to sell it.
They're allowed to have it.
Dude,
just for you,
just for you today.
I went and I got my
license from Dr Winkler,
md.
Shouldn't say the doctor's name.
TheSe doctors are all undercover.
Oh,
he's cool.
That's the thing.
It's all legit now.
Oh really?
No,
and I was.
I was afraid that what we were going
to see was this and it is a ridiculous
cottage industry of writing medical
marijuana prescription and I was thinking,
oh,
it's a shame that this is a diversion
of legitimate medical care resources and
to a certain extent it is,
but this is.
He was the nicest old dude and when he
came out of retirement to help patients
all day,
just chilling,
you know,
and you know,
he does get to help patients
occasionally as he says,
but you know,
because there's a lot of people that
just come in for their paperwork,
you know,
he's just writing scripts all day,
but you know,
it's karma and that man to
be a doctor and do that.
There's,
yeah,
because you're turning the guns,
the government away from people
you're covering for people.
And it's funny in Colorado though,
where it's not as well established.
So it hasn't been subjected
to market forces for as long.
The doctor still charged $200,
but my doctor charges more than
the 35 minutes to write a referral.
I don't wanna I don't want to say my
doctor's name because I don't want anybody
to get mad at them on the
outside of the building.
He went to jail for it.
And um,
he uh,
he did time and leave you.
I don't want,
if you went to jail for.
I know he's arrested.
I know he lost his license
and he had given back.
It was during the beginning
of the medical marijuana.
It's funny.
Back then you could use lose your
license for being involved in this.
Now you have to use your license
to get people pot.
Well,
yOu know,
I,
I was turned onto the whole medical
marijuana scene in part by my friend todd
mccormick.
Do you know todd taught store my friend
todd is a really brilliant guy when it
comes to any knowledge of cannabis or
hamper the history behind it and the
suppression of it had cancer himself,
you know,
he needs marijuana.
Like literally,
you know,
and knowing him,
I got to meet all sorts of people
like that that are inside the medical
community and most of them
are doing a great service.
You know,
most of 'em are getting
weed to people and you know,
there's nothing wrong with that,
but there's a few of them out there
that it just like the people in northern
California saying we should keep it
illegal because they make more money.
Oh yeah.
That's big,
isn't it?
That just shows you how twisted government
is that somebody's always benefits
in,
wants to benefit from the violence.
It's just sad that anybody would ever
want a profit on keeping something from.
From everybody when I know it
would be good for everybody.
You know the fact that you would vote
against legalization while you're selling
pot.
It's like,
man,
that's not good for you.
You're making a real creepy decision,
man.
Burning you would still be okay.
Everybody thinks that like people
are going to grow the wheat.
I'm not going to grow my weight.
What I pay fOr weed right now,
it's perfect.
I'll keep paying that forever.
You don't need it.
Nobody has to lose any money.
You don't have to be country
about this whole thing.
It's just completely ridiculous.
How many people are going gonna?
Start a weed farm.
Really
kNow pot heads out of that
kind of ambition.
Well,
if they want to,
they should be able to.
Man,
If you want to grow fucking tomatoes,
you should be able to grow tomatoes.
It should be legal.
well,
it's going to be like
who would grow tobacco?
You know?
Eventually that's what it's going to be,
but I want,
I want,
I want to tell a little story about my
experience this morning because I haven't
really had a blast.
We went right across the street to
la confidential and it's one of the
dispensary's in the
hollywood area and in place.
I want to give them a shout out.
This was a real operate confidential.
have,
you know,
I guess not,
and I'm going to,
I'm going to call out people
by name because they were.
They were awesome.
Okay,
cool.
And they said,
they said that they're not allowed to.
You're setting a precedent.
You will have to give shout
outs all the time from now on.
Well,
anybody stops.
You also have.
You'll also see I have an ulterior
motive here because the guy at the front,
his name was jeff and he looked like the
character from south park who's dead.
I'll just sad,
sad.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to derail my
story with that tragedy.
No,
I did it real.
I was just thinking about the cartoon,
but anyways,
he was,
uh,
you know,
we weren't allowed to film in there and
they were very professional about it and
who was understandable and
they had a no cellphone policy,
but they had,
they had,
they have a separate bar in the back.
so at first I went,
I talked to this,
a lovely young woman,
mickey,
and this is my ulterior motive.
I'm kind of hoping that
by giving her a shout out,
she will actually call me,
oh,
you're trying to get laid on this show.
That's ridiculous.
How dare you.
And it's such a mad struggle
and don't ever do that.
That's a terrible idea.
Terrible idea.
She'd never do that.
If you can't get laid without mentioning
a chicken here or even get to her to
hang out with you,
how much interest could she possibly have?
The last thing you want to do is give
a shout out on the air because what if
this doesn't work out?
What if this doesn't work out?
And then like a year from now,
your new wife who you
love more than anything,
you're like,
you gotta listen to this tape.
This is me on the joe rogan podcast.
Was like,
wow,
this is so amazing.
Who the fuck is nikki?
Who's nicky?
Well,
nicky.
Nicky didn't work out.
She didn't.
I,
yeah,
I gave her a shout out,
but she didn't.
She didn't go out with me like you.
You're still lose hope and you.
I do want to give a shout out to asa,
akira and tara patrick that we'll
just call you for no reason.
Just for no reason.
Just giving shout outs to hot porn stars.
Oh there you brian.
I went to.
She was great and this was great.
The customer service is really incredible.
It's my first time buying,
but I had gone to.
They're all high man.
They're going to be real friendly.
I went to the club and
breckenridge in Colorado,
the breckenridge cannabis club.
And for my youtube channel we did a
recording with my friend job weeks there
with his new local
currency mountain hours.
This was really exciting.
Yeah.
So they explained that they,
they have their own talk about monetary
policy because this was really awesome,
but mickey was,
was really helpful.
I got as a,
as a first time or discount,
a free hit of hash and I had
never had this before where they,
they use the blow torch over
the little metal device in,
into the front of the bomb
and they gave me two half
hits that were like for me,
a huge,
huge rips of hash that knocked me on
my ass and they have this beautiful
smoker's lounge in the bag.
Jake was there,
very helpful.
It was a,
it was a wonderful experIence.
And I asked them if there was,
if I could plug their
business and they said,
well we can't tell you
what to say but you know,
I said,
is there,
is there any message
that you want to get out?
And they said get involved,
you know.
And I think that's really cool to see
that most people aren't like those growers
in northern California.
They want people to get
involved in the issue.
They want people working in,
as he's,
as chef specifically said,
you know what,
this could be if it was fully legal,
classify what you're saying.
The reason why the people are in
northern California or intuit is because
they're selling it illegally.
They they want it to stay illegal.
They will either a lot of them,
but the grower,
the growers that are
selling to dispensary's,
they're not the ones who
are voting against legality.
A lot of it is the guys
who've been doing it,
old school where it's just
completely accepted up there.
I mean a big part of humboldt county
is comedy is based on marijuana.
That has just a fact and it's
just been sort of accepted,
but now not so much,
you know,
now it's a.
Then they also had the problem
with mexican gangs that
are running these forest.
They set up these things
in national forest,
but put up these farms.
Even the people here in the dispensary's
have an interest in the law,
not changing.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they haven't because it know if it's
fully legalized they just switch over
and start selling it
or they have the same.
No,
they have the same,
the same bullshit.
Financial interest in the
current government restricted
system that the people
in northern California
too and and most people.
My point is most people are good
people and the people that are like
confidential are good people.
Somebody I think you're saying that you
believe that you know how everyone who
runs a dispensary thinks
and you know you can't.
It's real hard to say that,
that they know.
I'm just saying my sense no,
because I do know other people
that are involved in the industry,
but that's not necessarily bad for them.
If it becomes legal,
they just can open up a weed shop.
They can switch from a
medical dispensary slash no,
no,
because it'll be more commercialized.
There'll be selling it at a
walmart in the cigarette section.
You know what I mean?
Like or with liquor stores it'll be,
it'll be,
it will be specialty shops,
but there was more
competition you'll have,
you'll end up in more legalization will
end up with a greater consolidation in
the market.
I don't necessarily think that's the case.
If it's to sell weed,
why?
I mean why would it have to be so
expensive that you'd have to go through
walmart with its thousand employees?
Why you could sell weed.
You could have like little locally,
locally.
There would be more.
There will be more competition.
Wonder,
I wonder how long it would
take before marijuana is legal.
As before coca cola gotten
business and started saying,
listen man,
we need to.
You know,
there's a big business.
Let's get a piece.
It's really fun to apply the economics
of this and then you start to understand
why the violence is happening in Mexico
because their business is being shredded
and they're fighting over a
territory that is rapidly shrinking.
I would.
It is.
THat's because marijuana
or drugs are illegal
in this country.
Swag anymore.
In America it's hard to find it.
Shitty mexican trash compactor.
We'd like the shit I used
to get in high school for,
you know,
$80 an ounce or whatever it was.
You can't find that anymore.
I had this epiphany.
I was in Kansas city where it's
as illegal as it is anywhere else.
I was there for,
for a gig a couple of weeks ago trying
to buy weed and it was like we were
trying to.
We were joking about it,
but we actually trying to find shitty
weed to see if we could do it and we
couldn't,
you know,
I bet east coast you could
still find find in Ohio.
I got a couple months ago.
It's out there,
you can get it,
but you see how much
it's because when it's,
when it's illegal in California and
it's still gray market for producers,
it puts pressure on the market in places
where it's harder to grow and so people
are able to get better weed from the
surplus in California and it's a better
deal for them.
Then they get the ship
that's up from Mexico.
I did comedy at that la confidential.
they used to do a or like a comedy shows
there and I did it with joey dia's,
no,
la confidential.
And they have like a stage
in the backyard they used to.
They stopped doing it though I heard.
Um,
but it was crazy because if
you were on later in the show,
like I was like second to last,
I was uh,
right after joey diaz
or something like that.
A beginning of show was awesome.
Second part of the show,
everyone was so fucked up from doing hash
and fucking weed and stuff like that.
Sitting at with drool
coming out of their mouth.
Just looking at the movements
you're doing with your hands too.
Did a show who the fuck
that I do a toronto with?
It was either a sam trip.
No,
it wasn't.
It was the ra should fear at thompson.
I forget who it was,
but we did it in this place in toronto.
That's,
I don't want to say the name because
it's probably illegal what they're doing,
but they have a pot shop and the front
where they sell bongs and shit in the
back.
They have a hot box,
this is a hot box.
Got 100 people boxed in with no
fucking ventilation whatsoever,
and everybody's hitting bongs and
vaporizers and they're passing blunts.
The air is so ridiculously
unhealthy and healthy.
It's all smoke that can't.
You got to.
It should be a little smoke,
a little air,
a little smoke of this was just nothing
but smoke to the point where the next
day my throat was sore.
I was like,
wow,
I might be fucked.
I was worried that it was going to mess
with my voice because it was nothing but
smoke for like an hour.
I've never been that high in my life.
It was ridiculous.
It was so.
There was so much thc in the air and no,
there was no air was all thc and carbon
dioxide has bad breath and people just
blitzkrieg I don't even
remember what I talked about.
I'd bet I did maybe five minutes
of material in an hour onstage.
It was preposterous,
which is going to be tonight.
Tonight's preposterous.
If you're around.
Ladies and gentlemen,
tonight we've got a 10:00 PM show at
the ice house comedy club right here in
lovely downtown pasadena where
they've spotted rabid bats.
So if you have a turtleneck,
put that shit on.
You don't want to get
jacked by a rabid bat.
Yeah,
we just released a 20 more tickets.
So good.
A comedy sitcom.
20 rabid bat bats in here.
um,
yeah we got tonight.
Ten pm show we got joey,
joey does.
And then there's one already should
fear dom I rera greg fitzsimmons.
Brian red band,
ico tanaka,
ryan mervis.
And our host is always a tony
hinchcliffe who's hilarious and me.
You dirty bitches.
So that's tonight a 10:00 show.
And of course we'll also have the ice
house chronicles that go on at the same
time.
And that is only available on the itunes
desk squad label adam coke cash in for
an ice house.
This is not the coldest place yet.
Yeah,
we already made those jokes to.
You weren't in the room.
Yeah,
you were dealing with shit.
That's what hacky material.
Well it's just called parallel thinking.
So don't be so hard on yourself.
So um,
how long have you been down here for me?
Just for this.
It kind of worked out.
I don't really realize that,
that it worked out,
but I was in Colorado for the mountain
hours event and then it was able.
I was able to come here.
But.
Well we got distracted by weed man.
We were actually,
when you want to tell me about,
I want to hear the currency thing that
you would tell me before the show about
the they have their own currency.
See?
Well,
well let's come back to that because
we were talking about the perspective,
you know,
how I used to be asleep,
right.
And how so many in in my audience are
excited to have me appear on your podcast
and to be able to share this perspective
with you because it's about sharing the
joy of standing out to government,
of standing up to the bully of actually
seeing yourself as part of this process
of humanity evolving.
And they know that you share
a lot of the premises of this,
of,
of distrust for authority of,
of you.
You're good understanding
of what government is.
And,
and,
and the exploitation behind it,
but what,
what we're doing is actually working to
change the paradigm and get people more
involved.
We're not so much a political movement
as an anti political movement and that
we're not.
We understand that politics is
pathological behavior when you're,
when you're advocating for
more government control,
when you're saying that we
need government to do this and,
and we are helping humanity by spreading
this message that it is a universal
moral message of that,
you know,
don't hit,
don't steal,
not unless you have a badge
or a gun of the government,
you know,
government is an opinion with a gun and
getting people to see that and move past
that.
And as,
as,
as activists,
you know,
and it's,
it's funny you talked about what it's
like being a celebrity for yourself and
you know,
you're,
you're a legitimate celebrity.
And then there's like there's political
celebrity and then there's me minor
political celebrity and I still get some
of the same experience of people having
a relationship with me
before you meet them and,
and you know who that is and what,
what,
what though,
what you have with,
with your presence,
your ability
to get people to get more involved,
to share this perspective,
to enjoy standing up
to the man that people,
people in your position
can use your presence to,
to better effect this change
and be a part of this.
And I wanted to,
I wanted to open the podcast by saying
I'm from the revolution and I'm here to
recruit you.
I don't know how to respond
to that last creepy part.
You're gonna need to work out together,
right?
Just wants both of us to
leave the room right now.
Begging him.
Uncomfortable.
There's too much bromance,
motherfucker.
Do we cross that line man?
Smoking a little joint?
Yeah.
You know man,
that's this one.
It's very cool for you to.
Yeah,
we can finish that joint.
Where would we put that thing?
It's in the.
Don't ask for it.
You know,
you know adam can be your new flashlight.
Oh brian.
That was just.
That was so stupid that that's one of
those things where you remember when you
did that show the other
day and you're like,
man,
people,
they didn't know who I was.
They hated me.
Yeah.
That's how normal person
where you're asked to you.
It's like people didn't
understand for years.
I had to tell people that he's.
He kind of grows on you.
It's a weird thing.
You know?
It takes awhile for your
sense of humor to make sense,
but even that you should
be embarrassed about.
Yeah.
Even you should be embarrassed
about that last one ever.
I think.
I just imagine it would be funny.
I don't think so.
I don't think it's funny though.
A of card
issues.
Kid.
You got issues.
You're not even high right now.
Yeah,
I am.
I've been smoking all the
whole time in the back.
That's what you do.
You leave.
Well,
you know I'm going to say make
it so you're not allowed to talk.
If you get over a certain high,
we need to get a
breathalyzer test for you.
They should have that,
right?
They don't have that,
but watch out.
They don't have weed breathalyzers today.
Like how much you've smoked,
like how fucked up you are?
Not.
Well,
I don't think it's relative.
You know,
it's,
it's so hard to figure out like what is
for you mean it's the same blood level,
right?
It's just your tolerance.
Your tolerance doesn't
decrease it in your body.
So it's like you could have a little
bit of pot in the person who's a fucking
rookie and they are going to be blasted,
but if you carry that
same amount of pot new,
you'll be fun.
So is there a thc levels or something?
Right.
But I'm saying thc is something that
your body gets comfortable with.
It could be alcohol too.
This is why there should be an
objective measurement of impairment.
None out with alcohol.
There's a,
it should be a body fat mike thing
like where they do not be that.
It should be an impairment thing,
you know,
I want it to be body fat.
Come on,
I got pulled over once and I wasn't drunk.
They thought I was and who was not.
I just dropped my cell phone in between
my legs and I reached in and I changed
lanes for a second,
but it was nobody near
me but a cop behind me.
So,
uh,
I did all their shit.
Man.
I have good balance man.
I got no problem.
I did all their shit.
Touch my note.
I'm like,
I'm not drunk at all,
like I just want you to know.
So I did all that shit and
then they asked me to do a
breathalyzer test and um,
I was like,
really?
Do I really have to do that?
You know,
I'm not drunk like this is silly.
LiKe I could do that with.
And then they sat,
they got together and they huddled in
the nygaard we're going to let you go.
Thank you.
Because I really wasn't drunk.
I told the truth,
I drop my shit,
but there was that weird
moment where I was like,
I wasn't guilty.
Are you going to fuck
me just because you can?
Yeah.
But I was like,
is this going to be some weird thing
where I'm gonna wind up handcuffed in the
back of a car?
Because I'm making sense,
you know,
I just did all your shit.
I just touched my nose.
I'm perfect.
I got good balance.
Everything's,
there's no fuck ups.
I'm following your pan fucking sober,
right?
I mean I think I might've had
one beer like three hours ago.
It was like ridiculously sober,
but it was a weird thing.
Were like,
whoa,
what if I blow pop?
I mean,
what is,
what is legal?
I don't know what the fuck legal is.
Is it
one beer an hour or something like that?
You say that,
but I don't know.
I don't know what that is.
Like when if you had a beer an hour ago,
you are noT fucking drunk.
Will you test drunk?
No,
no,
it's that you can oxidize
one drink per hour.
So if you're one,
if you drink the effect of that
serving of alcohol is gone an hour.
If you have three drinks,
it's three hours for it to be gone.
Is that three hours that
you can be tested for,
or three hours that you're impaired by?
I don't know.
I don't drink anymore.
You don't drink at all?
No.
I mean,
occasionally I'll have a glass of wine,
but no,
I quit drinking the cops
that I ran into a cool,
but they didn't have to be,
you know,
it could have been,
could have been coming off with some
terrible people and I'm always very polite
if anything happens,
but uh,
it's a weird feeling like you could
just lock me up right now when you,
when you watch like the videos of those
guys slamming you on the ground and
arresting everybody for hugging you,
you just want to go in and
you just want to rest them.
You want to just pull them out
of society when it makes them,
make them,
watch this,
make them sit in the theater with people,
sit on the stage and I want
you to sit in behind you.
We're going to play that video.
And then I want you to
respond to all these people,
the citizens,
the tax payers.
They're going to have
some questions for you.
they don't even have any vested interest
and they have no emotional connection
to you or,
or adam.
And guess what?
Fuck face.
That's going to be a real uncomfortable
feeling and people need to understand
that,
that that's what this whole thing called
internet video and that's called the
free market.
yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
It's basically the same
and the government is
out in front of that.
When you say government is
going to run public safety,
that's what you get.
Yeah.
Well,
it doesn't have to be that way.
You know?
First it will be much more of it.
I always say,
so you're on board.
I can sign you up for
a tour with revolution,
but this podcast and I like to play pool.
Very busy doing comedy in the revolution.
If I'm amanda know you absolutely know
what you absolutely are to be fair
because you are,
you are spreading important information
and you are sharing a very important
perspective that is about
challenging authority,
but you know there are lots
about challenging yourself.
Next level.
It's challenging yourself as well.
You know what I've always said is that
what's going to change this world is the
youth,
the people that are growing up right now,
the people that are listening to this
in their dorm rooms and people that are
listening to this and that are high school
bedroom where trying to keep it down
because her dad would yell at them because
he disagrees with all the shit we're
talking about.
Those Are the people that are going to
be involved and exposed to information
that our generation and
the previous generations,
that rumsfeld's of the world,
they never thought that this
was going to be an option.
They never thought that information
would be so freely distributed between
anyone everywhere,
all over the world.
That was never in the plan.
They thought they're going
to be able to run shit.
Business as usual.
So what we're seeing now
with world dominanCe and the
craziness and the chaos of
foreign policy,
we're seeing like the
the last ripples of this,
this emerging creature,
this emerging new human technology,
symbiotic.
So right now it's pushing
all the old things out.
It's pushing all the old paradigms away
and it's going to dissolve standard
forms of government and law enforcement
to dissolve all that shit because you're
going to be a part of everybody.
It's going to happen.
That's where it's going.
It's going to be technological
or it'll be the next stage of,
of our physical evolution if you you know,
if you're allowed to use that term
when it comes to something that's
technologically driven,
because I think it may be.
I mean,
I think it may be something that someone
creates and they create an ability to
enhance the human body and if you look
at what they're doing now with genetic
engineering and they're creating
fucking bladders and petri dishes,
they're.
They're working on developing
artificial organs there.
The workup.
Eventually they're going to look at the.
Once they figure out more and more
and more about the human body,
they're going to figure out
parts of it and got to go.
We're gonna fix everything.
We're just going to turn this into.
We're just going to remove all the greed.
There's no more greed and we're
going to install community.
This is the newest formula.
We've developed a new brain simpler
than that.
it's simpler than that
therapy man therapy.
Everybody just gets therapy
and government goes away.
What do you think that therapy iS
good enough to work on everybody?
Well,
eventually as we have greater
prosperity in general,
we have more leisure time
to address these issues.
We have more time that we're not spending
scrambling to maintain our quality of
life.
Yeah,
I think that's one of one of the next
phases we're going to be coming to.
Well,
if we got an issue,
you have to start with the
poorest part of the country.
Right?
If you have,
if you're allowed to
use your resources here,
only because otherwise we should start
at the poorest part of the world.
You know,
that's what you really should be trying
to balance this whole motherfucker out.
I mean,
that should be the ultimate goal because
it could have been no real peace.
Well,
the answer is some sort of every human
being equitably into the market so then
means anybody can move to America.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
No,
it's.
The highway is so fucking
crowded right now.
Do you know?
Crazy,
it would be if indians could just
come here on their own free will.
There's a billion of them.
You ready to apply austrian economics in
a way that's going to bake your noodle
just a little bit when you talk about
roads and the government monopoly and
subsidization,
subsidization of the auto industry
and the oil and gas industry.
If we didn't have the
government doing that,
eisenhower who built the interstate
highway system to serve the needs of the
military and like where I live in New
Mexico or where I'm from in New Mexico
where the
speaker of the state house can have an
intersection move to where he wants it to
make his land worth more and we didn't
have all that methane being forced into
that.
We would.
We would be.
You were already at the point where we
should have cars that are self driving,
but if it wasn't for government keeping
all this research and development
stifled with intellectual property,
you know,
who killed the electric car?
Have you seen that documentary?
You can imagine how much you see.
There's just that one government policy
of intellectual property of so that oh,
you invented a battery and you bought
a piece of paper that describes it from
someone you can keep that from humanity.
Do you know?
I mean,
do you see how much that holds us back?
You see how much the
exploitation by government
keeps us from evolving into that
state of greater technology.
I mean even even like,
why do we not have self
driving cars right now?
Because why do we not have
twenties of the technological era?
This is the last,
but it's still holding us back.
No,
it's still going.
It's still holding us know,
incredible romantic.
To be able to hear the rumble of a v
eight step on the gas when you want to
instead of just being
trapped in a fucking grid,
like your own little trolley car.
Maybe you want to have a little passion.
Man.
I fucking car.
I can't fucking believe there are so
many god damn liberal status here in
southern California when all around them
they are wasting hours and hours and
hours of their day.
Well,
I get.
I guess it's because they sit there
and they listened to propaganda,
npr and their communities in their
cars and they don't do about it.
Geez.
maybe having the government
managed transportation
resources isn't a good idea.
Well,
I don't think that's
what they're thinking.
They're thinking,
how the fuck did I get to work?
Well,
it's because their propaganda is the
whole time they're in the car to begin
with.
Well,
I don't know if that's
necessarily what their problem is.
Their problem is they have to work.
The problem is that they have to have
a job and if you have to be in fucking
santa monica at 9:00 in the morning,
there's only one way to do it.
Another way of looking
at what we're doing,
you know,
but that's not necessarily designed
by the government to keep you stupid.
That's just we have the resource.
We have too many god damn.
People know this is a side
effect of government though.
What's a side effect of them being
incompetent race and that you have the,
the through the system of
concentrations of wealth and power,
you have unnatural incentives to live
in concentrated population areas and if
anything la is still
relatively spread out.
I mean compared to
certain cities or in asia,
I think they said vancouver is the
most densely populated city in the,
in this continent,
which I thought was really fascinating.
I would've never thought
that it was that crowded,
but I guess it's smaller and
it's got a high population,
but like there's areas of vancouver that
are most densely I would've thought in
New York for sure when you have thought
that it was New York would be more
densely populated.
Central park In the middle still.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
It's a great place though.
I mean,
fascinating place.
It's certainly a hive of,
of instant energy.
I never want to live there,
but it is a fun place to vIsit.
I agree with you.
I've thought about spending time there.
I've thought about like maybe living
there for like a couple months just for a
goof just to see what it was.
I think it's good to mix a mix your brain
up and I almost moved there to bergen
girlfriend told you need to.
You need a friend.
Hey joe.
He's
someone who's going to talk to you
when it comes to shit like this.
Can't get too crazy son.
I have an awesome app.
I have an awesome new app
that's going to blow your mind.
It's gonna.
Make it kind of freak out a little.
But what does that.
It's a program called crime map and
you could download on your iphone.
I'm not sure if android or not and it
uses gps to tell you where you're out on
that,
you know,
uses the map,
but that tells you all the
crimes around that that had,
has happened within the one day.
Like they're just where I live.
There's like burger lee.
There's,
there's been like assaults.
There's been,
you know,
home invasions.
There's like in it,
it will freak you the fuck.
It was all just andy dick,
but like,
look at it.
Here's,
here's an example of where we're at right
now at the ice house and you can see
that there's been car
accIdents and crimes.
There's been one mugging,
it looks like a.
And it will show it if you just zoom out,
like,
just like,
look at this.
This is going to freak you out though,
like just for a pasadena,
uh,
yesterday.
Just like,
look how much fucking crying
in my car.
Accidents and,
and shit like that.
It will.
And it's cool to do it at your house
though because then you're like,
what the fuck happened?
See,
I think something like this goes back to
this problem that I have with the human
body in this technological society.
It's not capable of
keeping up with everything.
There's too much shit coming at you and
it's too much shit coming at you that
you really don't need to know about.
I mean,
maybe you should know that there'd
been a 150 different car accidents in
pasedena,
but that is going to
fuck with your head man.
You know,
when,
when there's such a thing as rational.
Again,
you should be dealing with your
life and your reality right now,
but instead you're dealing with
realities hundreds of yards away,
a mile away,
but all six miles away and all these
realities are interfering into your
reality,
but also wouldn't you like to
know just for safety reasons,
like be able to check
your house and be like,
holy shit,
there's been seven home
invasions in the last two weeks.
I need to up my shit here.
Alright,
get the most.
Certainly.
Yeah.
No,
you got a good point.
No doubt about it.
All I'm saying is it's just weird
that we have this ancient brain,
certainly a good quad.
I certainly prefer to be able
to access information than not,
but it's.
It's a weird brain that we have where
we essentially have the same mind of
people that lived in the past.
When you write things
down on animal skins,
those dudes we find like their parchments,
their brands are exactly the same as ours,
but when they find like 2000 year
old documents or thousand year old,
holy shit,
they.
Their brains were exactly like ours.
But think of how much more shit is in our,
but we're also not
remember.
We don't know how to fucking skin a
fucking go and use the skin as a brawl or.
THat's true too.
So it took stuff away that
we don't have to use it.
Yeah,
but no,
the access to information,
access to information,
you're finding out about things that
are happening in Pakistan and Syria and
Japan is a nuclear problem and what's
going on in Russia and chechen and the
Philippines and there's an earthquake
and Thailand and this shit is coming at
you all day every day.
If you get twitter,
if you get on cnn.com,
if you go and access the new sites,
you are constantly inundated by actions
and things that are happening that
literally have nothing to do with you,
but it's a constant barrage
of them because you were
in contact with essentially
billions of people and all the information
that they project out there and to
the internet and it's our little shitty
brains are not meant to have that much
information coming at us.
We still hAve this tribal body that
wants to move around and find animals and
grow vegetables and this is the same
fucking body and this body is getting
youtube videos and fucking all kinds of
crazy information coming out at all day,
24 hours a day.
It's almost like we're standing in the
middle of a river and we just trying to
hold out of the water.
It's almost like it's too much.
It's almost like for every one person
there's way too much information that you
have to absorb about everything.
It's like to even focus on one thing.
It's like you could give
your whole life to politics.
You have your whole life to observing
politics and still barely have a grasp on
everything that's going on.
All the sneaky little fucking underhanded
deals that are taking place all over
the place.
How could you possibly manage them?
How could you possibly
even researched them?
How can you possibly even read all the
documents that have been transcribed,
but every different case?
You can't do it.
It's insanity to people passing the laws.
don't even read them.
Let's wait.
While and I was talking about before
about we're all apart of something,
we all have our,
a part of this weird fucking
machine of humanity and some people,
their part is to figure out how
to make an alienware computer.
Your part is to rile people up on the
internet and I don't know what the fuck my
part is,
but everybody has a piece that,
dude,
we're making cars.
They have art.
Are
you get people passIonate because you
are passionate because you care and you,
you,
you understand what the silver.
Let me go back to what brian said
because he said something really profound
about possible.
You just woke up the dry.
We'll go up the drag.
No,
because what you said about every
development like taking away a part of,
of what it is to be human being.
Right,
and I remember just well what it used to
be to be a human being like hunting and
trapping and fishing
and living off the land.
Growing your own vegetables,
knowing what to eat when you're sick.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
by the way,
it's almost impossible to do that now.
Try try to fucking living off the land.
Good luck is that some way evolutionary
and you can't hold a job and live off
the land the same time,
but I can explain this actually
through my last dmt experience.
Oh,
I know.
Which is really interesting because I.
I've been posting my dmt experiences on
my youtube channel and I've good way to
get arrested.
I've had three sessions of interested
enough times that they're not going to
come after me for that.
I've had.
I've had three sessions and every time
I've smoked twice and this last time has
been exponentially more complex.
The first
time started with a blob
of psychedelic colors.
The second time it had a bit of a female
personality and a bit of a form to it,
but not much more.
The third time I saw building structures
and scenery type stuff and the fourth
time I saw what I described as my
face being raped with the truth of the
universe and it was this complex
vision and the last time,
the third time in the first launch I saw
a pattern of like colored bricks moving
at me,
unfolding in different ways and going
through different color shifts and showing
different shapes.
And it was like,
wow,
now it's really complex and
trying to show me something.
And then I did another rip.
Right.
Then as soon as I came out of that one
and I spent half the time laughing.
It was just a beautiful experience,
but I couldn't even describe the
whole thing and I was videotaping it.
So I tried afterwards to talk to the
camera and describe everything I did and
this one we actually as we speak and
versus the dmt part two and two point one
or uploading with disclaimers on them.
And then part three is,
is in the can and I'm going
to be editing and it soon.
But that,
that second trip and the third
time was just overwhelming.
I couldn't even describe it and it was
so much coming at me and and and in
different forms and in different
colors and different shapes,
but what I experienced
in the middle of that,
that was the just had me laughing with
joy the entire time was inexperience of
the pure human will and at first it was
like a vision of a brain floating in a
psychedelic space,
whatever.
I don't even know how to
describe it and I'm sure you.
You know what I'm talking about though,
where you're in that space
space listening this experience,
and then I.
Then it wasn't the brain and then
it was my consciousness and you.
You realize that your consciousness is
separate from your brain and that it's
still a product of your biology,
but that there was something in the middle
of it that is the human will that is
distinct.
That is who we are.
Because if you think about it,
we're not.
PartIcles were waves.
You know what defines us is not our matter
that is recycled every seven years or
whatever it is that all your
cells are replaced in your body.
You are a wave of energy.
Everything that gives you
identity as a human being,
as as an entity is a wave and and what
I experienced and what do you mean by a
wave?
Well,
what gives you form?
It's not.
It's not your body,
it's not the material of your body.
it's the course of your life,
the the person that you were as a baby,
the body that you were seven years later
did not have a single molecule in it
that was in it when you were
born and every seven years your,
your entire body is replaced
and all matter can be analyzed.
Your neurons,
right?
Well,
we even then they're there.
The molecules are cycled out.
It doesn't matter.
I'm not a physicist.
I don't care about the details of that.
Thinking about life.
That's why neurodegenerative the cell.
So the cell structures,
you do absolutely heal from them,
but all of the matter
is,
is recycled.
Although if you go down to the son,
the son molecular level,
you know,
everything can be analyzed as a
particle or a wave and anything.
I just was trying to figure
out like if you know how to,
what's the,
you know,
w w what's the best way for someone
to try to wrap their head around?
What,
what you mean by that?
Because when I,
I kind of don't understand
what you're saying,
but when you say you're not a particle,
your wave,
what exactly do you mean by that?
Well,
what are you,
what defines you?
What devices?
And this isn't a question of physics,
this is a question of philosophy.
What defInes you,
joe rogan,
who are you?
I'm just this dude that gets
to say what joe rogan does.
So what are you the matter in your body?
Um,
I'm certainly in my consciousness,
my choices.
So are you the thoughts in your brain?
I would imagine that you are wherever
the thoughts resonate from whether or not
it really is in your brain or whether
it's in every aspect of your body.
It's just your Brain projects it,
whether or not it's even the brain that
projection with him to the brain tunes
it in,
whether it's like a frequency and use.
Use this body as a vehicle.
There's people that
believe that I don't know,
but that's what I experienced
what I experienced in my last dmt.
But you were high as fuck.
That's right.
That's.
You got to always remember
you were high as fuck.
Whenever someone tells me like
they had a psychedelic experience,
I said,
look,
I've had a lot of them.
They've changed my life.
They're beautiful.
They're amazing with whatever
that comes out of it,
but you always have to open the door to
the possibility that you were just high
as fuck and this is some shit that
you might've already known anyway,
so I don't know whether or not you're
really communicating with somebody.
When you do damn tay,
it seems.
Oh,
I don't believe.
No.
I don't believe in any of that shit.
I don't know my baby man.
It might be lifeforms.
It does something to your brain and learn
something to yourself and things are
exposed to your consciousness
that wouldn't be otherwise.
I think that's really important that,
but it also could be some sort of a
chemical doorway to another dementia.
Communication by
the evidence is that dimethyltryptamine
is something they believe your body
produces when you're in periods of extreme
stress or when your body thinks it's
going to die and if you
follow all the different
myths and different cultures,
beliefs in the afterlife,
I mean so many of them involve going
towards the light and these crazy visions
and what those are probably or near
death experiences because your brain is
tripping out on dmp and
that's a much more rational,
very well be real that we think of.
We oNly think of ourselves as
real because we can make noise,
can hit you.
You can feel away from physics that
99 percent of this is empty space.
Yeah,
we don't.
yeah.
Well that's certainly
a part of the problem.
We don't necessarily know what
the fuck is really going on here.
You know,
this thing really might be a simulation,
but this is the science behind that.
This is what I experienced and this is
what was profound about it to me was that
it was.
I could only describe it
as pure human will and I,
and,
and I don't.
I don't want to say it was an out of
body experience because that describes it
wrong,
but it was an experience where my
consciousness was separated from the rest
of my being.
That was what you took out of it.
You felt like that was what
the experience was for me.
Right.
And that was a very empowering experience.
to get back to what,
brian,
when you say lou,
when you say like,
by your being,
do you mean by like your,
your,
your culture or your language?
Like you were free of all that.
He would just,
uh,
being.
Did you feel that?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You with no context,
right?
No.
Comes,
like a singularity,
you know,
and this is,
it's funny.
This is how I think of the effect of
marijuana when I smoke weed usually,
and it's the.
If your consciousness is,
and this is a crude metaphor,
but a point moving around in your brain
point of light say than marijuana makes
it a more diffuse light.
And sometimes that means
exploring different things.
And I think that explains the creative
legendary benefits of marijuana.
I agree,
but it also means it's sometimes
harder to put sentences together.
Yes.
And sometimes it's hard to
really get the idea and,
and hold it doWn.
You know,
it's like these new doors
present themselves and you
have to stop and look at it
all and go.
But I'm inspired,
man.
I'm like,
this is,
this is a really exciting thing for
me to get to be on your podcast.
Well,
I'm inspired to have you on man.
It's cool to hear that you enjoy the show.
So anyway,
so to what brian was saying though,
to what brian was saying about brian,
what were you saying?
Um,
something about fucking a Jack
Daniels bottle or something.
Yeah,
that's what it was.
But no,
It was about people forget how to kill
goats and shit and make bikinis out of
them,
but I don't think they ever really did.
Historically we can see the
technological singularity coming,
right?
We see that coming and we can
see if we don't fuck it up.
Right.
And see sooner or later we're going to
have taco copters and food's going to
drop out of the sky for us on our cars
will drive themselves or whatever the
case is going to be.
But I think that there's
someone else coming,
you know,
when every surface in the,
around us as a touch screen and,
and,
and we just get to that level of
prosperity and that's coming within our
lifetimes because it's
happening so exponentially.
I see this as,
you know,
who knows how long it's gonna take,
but again,
an urgency for me to help
humanity evolve past status,
um,
but will,
we're coming to is a state of greater
experience in our day to day lives of that
pure human will that
we're evolving to that.
And you know,
I know this is silly,
but the first time I heard the
term technological singularity,
which describes that point at which we
have computer smarter than human brains,
is I thought,
oh,
that's when all of our brains
are plugged into the matrix.
And we're all this hive mind.
And we've all replaced every
individual brain cell in our,
in our skulls with computer chips,
you know,
like the,
the,
that,
but who knows what that's gonna look like,
but what,
but what we're going to experience as
human beings and who knows if our waves
are going to ride that long,
you know,
if they're,
if they're going to last that long,
but I think most people alive today are,
you know,
especially young people are going to
live to experience this and we have a
special motivation than to make sure
that the world that experiences this
technology is one that
is evolved past statism,
the,
the design,
this thing of government,
of,
of imposing our will
on others by of saying,
well,
if it's
51 percent,
then it's okay.
You know,
of,
of saying they engaging in,
in this,
this truly pathological behavior.
But I'm obviously very optimistic.
Yeah,
no,
you are very optimistic
and I hope you're right.
Um,
you might be.
Who the fuck knows?
I would love it if the story turned out
that we all pulled it together in the
long run.
I'm constantly disappointed by people.
I'm constantly disappointed by stories
when I hear about the collapse of Greece
and all,
I'm constantly disappointed like real.
Can anybody fucking keep
it together anywhere?
I'm constantly disappointed.
Currency on that note.
Hold on a second,
but then I also look at all the
shit that people have accomplished.
What the fuck ever would've
figured out how to build a bridge?
Who the fuck ever figured
out how to make airplanes?
Who,
how?
How was there a dude
who really figured out,
I put satellites up in the
air so I can watch direct tv?
How is that how?
How did all that happen?
If and if all that happened,
I hold out hope for the
possibility that people could,
as much as they have achieved creatively
and technologically with ingenuity,
could also reach the same
level of excellence with
their social engineering and
the way they treat each other and the
way they develop a community and the way
they project the idea that it's way
better to have a world where everyone is
happy.
Then to have a world where a few people
dominate people and we have to figure
out how to do it from the
ground up and it's got to be,
you got to figure out how
to raise children better.
You've got to figure out how to raise
children better and you've got to deal
with children that are at that are,
you know,
in foster homes and that's
got to be handled way better.
You have to look at human
beings as resources and
potential problems if they're
not,
you know,
the last thing anybody wants
to do is grow up through life.
Just constantly dealing
with a fucked up childhood.
I have so many friends That were abused
as children and they are constantly in
battle with this well into their thirties,
constantly at battle with their childhood.
You know,
and that's because people raising kids,
they just,
they just do it their way.
It's the Most important resource
that we have as human beings.
And we used to have a
whole fucking community.
We used to have tribes of us 50,
60 monkey people and we
all fucked each other.
So nobody knew who the real daddy was
anyway and they are raising these babies
and you know,
the,
the whole community and the
tribe raised each other.
They all stayed together.
When that shit slowly start expanding
into cities and people slowly lost there,
you know,
you get that diffusion of responsibility
feeling where things are happening.
It Doesn't feel like it belongs to you.
It's all those people over there.
You,
you can't be living with
those people over there.
It should be a giant community or not.
This is some halfassed
way we're doing it today.
The way we're treating our society.
It's like,
it's like you're in my tribe,
but you're not really.
I don't know.
You do.
You know,
you just lived down the hall from me.
But still we're all in
the same fucking tribe.
That's the weirdest thing ever.
It's like your enemy could
be inside your tribe.
That should be impossible.
We should figure out a way where we
are treating everybody the same way.
this is one of the specific benefits of
technology I'm looking forward to in the
immediate.
And it's scary when
government control shit like the laser
that can read your chemistry from,
from starbucks really like that.
And.
But if you think about it,
you know what we have with what we're
about to have a head mounted iphone,
right?
We've got google glasses.
That shit's getting smaller,
faster,
better that laser thing.
Eventually that's going to be embedded
in your contact lens with the rest of
your smartphone and you're in your ass
and have an injection son eventually
going to be an injection.
It's going to be an intramuscular you
get in the ass because it's a big muscle.
It's not going to hurt.
It's going to be deep inside the tissue.
Boom,
you're hooked up for wifi,
but you got information coming in google.
The only problem is if you,
if,
if the early chips fuck up,
they have to go in your ass and pull
them out and sometimes you keep a scar.
People would do it.
Start rusting.
The inevitable symbiotic connection
between humans and machines is no clearly
more easily proven than with phones.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
I fucking panic if I leave my phone,
if I drive in my car and I
hold the house and I'm like,
I don't have my phone.
Oh yeah,
I'll be 10 minutes late and it rather
than not be there or you'll be getting the
shakes.
Right.
Have you,
have you tried to help
yourself away from that?
like I like it.
I've been slowly melting myself away
from facebook and twitter and my phone.
Like I used to be like every time somebody
texts me I have to text them back and
have to do the call.
Now I just don't even like I'll throw
my phone and just not look at it for two
hours just because it
is so like two hours.
It a long time know exactly.
But before I was like 10 minutes,
I was checking my twitter
or replying to her text.
I can't,
I'm trying not to do.
I don't want you to bother my how crazy
benson that doug benson gets all of his
tweets on his phone.
So if you really want to
fuck with doug benson,
just tweet him a lot of shit all day
and constantly get fucking vibrations in
his bucket
that his phone doesn't.
He can't,
you,
you don't get any of his message.
I don't get any of his tweets and texts.
Rather he sent me like four or five texts.
I didn't get a single one of them,
you know,
he did it again,
like uh,
the following day he's just been like,
doing this,
you get this and it doesn't
say delivered like how it does,
but then you text him and it worked fine.
That's so strange.
But then he texts me back and it was okay.
Yeah,
he texts me back.
It doesn't make any sense now.
Yeah.
He was showing me all the texts
he'd been since June 20th,
probably the cia,
the cia and the dea are looking at
him as a potential source of all the
marijuana in California,
if you can imagine,
found out the dog was a drug
dealer and that he was being wired.
That's why he's following us around.
The cia had already compromised him.
We were in vegas after the show,
we went to go play some slot machines and
we were both smoking out of apples and
just like getting a.
By the way I should say,
I don't really believe that.
I shouldn't even say that on the internet
because somebody fox go to lock onto
that and thank you.
I was being serious,
sorry,
but we were smoking some kind of butter
or something out of an apple like weed
butter and smoking weed
butter or something.
I forget what it was called,
something
weird,
but we got so stone we're going to go
play slots and we found the wizard of oz
slot machine and if you ever have a
chance get really fucking baked and play
that it trips that we were blown away.
We both almost having panic
attacks playing this slot.
It's just really intense and it has
like this really good sound system like
that's all around you and then like this
humongous screen and it's just a trip.
It's like wizard of oz slots.
You're freaking out and you're constantly
checking your little truck crime
tracker.
Right?
It's a small group.
That's what they need.
A hooker tracker where hookers
or two at mandalay bay.
Let's go.
It's common.
I guarantee it's coming
and they should have like.
People should have like
yellow lights over.
They had like,
well she's not really a hooker,
but she has
thinking about it.
Does have some bills.
Have you ever stayed at the wynn?
That's amazing.
Amazing.
Like all tens.
Everywhere.
There's so much security
though that you're not like,
like the nightclubs,
you know?
How about to stop and just stare at the
nightclub for a second or you have this
guy coming out of nowhere that goes.
Please continue to walk.
We just found the next location from adam
coachella versus the man coming to you
live.
Civil disobedience.
Body slammed in vegas.
Silly,
silly people.
That wind is where.
That's the dj ts doe guy,
right?
Yeah.
What kind of music do you listen to?
The dude like all rage
against the machine all day.
I'm gLad you would say that,
but no
fish.
I'm kind of embarrassed to answer that.
I like,
I don't have time for music anymore.
Oh,
you guys were in dora for,
you know,
for,
for what do you do with
your time that you don't,
that you don't know?
All I do is this.
I read the news,
I make youtube videos.
I,
you know,
I'm getting better about my daily
routine and get enough sleep.
I used to be really manic and
stay up all night editing videos.
That always makes you
look a little less crazy.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
now people think about the
government like he's stoned.
Say no,
you know what?
I'm stone,
so you're just stayIng up making
these videos and putting them out.
Well now I'm getting
better about my routine.
I'm getting some interns that are
really helpful and are able to handle my
productivity yet.
Well.
I've actually been operating as an
llc for the last couple of years,
but you are the man dude.
You're a part of the machine.
You're an llc now.
This is how I don't pay as many taxes.
Oh,
so you stick it to the give them man.
less weapons.
Exactly.
I'm not going to fund new.
You can protest all you want as
long as you keep paying your taxes.
Pretty ridiculous that the government
doesn't give you a receipt.
Like,
tell me what you spent my money on.
Can you at least give me a breakdown?
They don't even have the
courtesy to give you a breakdown.
You know Mr. Koch cash you spend
$40,000 in taxes last year.
This is what went to.
You have to dig for it.
But no,
I,
I like 90 percent of my time.
You know that I'm outside of the house.
If it's not for work,
like going to a political
events but it's not working.
I love what I
do.
Consider it.
If it works,
you're driven.
You're absolutely love it.
Yeah.
And it,
you know,
there are parts of it that our work,
but it's,
it's as a whole.
It's not work.
I mean I love,
I love doing.
I mean we can say it's not work.
It's there.
There's always work involved.
Even in not work,
even athletics,
it's fucking work involved
and all and everything,
but you want to do it is you want the
exact different feeling than working for
somebody that's working for an
intrinsic goal or for an extrinsic goal.
I'm,
I'm enjoying the experience,
I'm loving my life.
And then you're doing it
with the right frame of mind.
With the right spirit.
you're doing it in the spirit of trying
to change things and help things.
You're not doing it in the spirit
of self randomization or you know,
you're not trying to pump yourself up.
And so I go to wholefoods,
I go to target,
I go to the gym to go to gold's gym,
self grandization.
How do you say it?
Brian is what sells
grandization.
is that what it is?
That's what it is,
right?
So alpha grandization right?
Sounds so sexy.
Doesn't it
sound sexy?
So you just go to the gym.
You just throw on pandora.
Yeah.
And I go,
I go to the mma gym.
I'm training with a team.
Lloyd irvin in northern beautiful.
Couldn't do any better.
That's a beautiful place to train.
I wish he's created a lot
of really high level guys,
a lot of high level jujitsu guys.
I wish I had more like mentorship,
but I've only been there
since february and I,
you know,
I travel a lot on mentorship
after february son.
I'm onlY,
I've only,
I'm only going like two
or three days a week,
so on average to get in whatever you
can get in and if you're on a load,
you know,
if you're on the road,
dude,
hindu squats,
hindu pushups,
you can get a ferocious workout
and you're fucking hotel room,
you know,
that's like half the battle,
especially when it comes to grappling,
half the battle's being in shape.
If you're not in shape,
it's fucking.
People just outlast you.
And the other half is knowing.
The other half is knowing this
is like the more you know on nbc,
do you have a goal?
What you're trying to realize
with your show and with the,
you know,
your idea of,
of a revolution.
Do you have a goal?
Try enlightened people.
Are you trying to change things?
Like what is your,
what's your idea?
You see it as part of a larger goal of
evolving past statism and getting past
this particular phase of human evolution
where we institutionalize all of our
desires to dominate and control others
by force into government and you know,
you understand this,
you've supported ron paul,
you've come out and and and you see
when a candidate speaks from this
philosophy,
and this is what we have in common
is this idea of volunteerism,
of,
of all human interactions being voluntary,
free of force,
fraud and coercion and understanding
that government is what George Washington
described it as.
It is not eloquence or reason.
It is like four or it is like fire.
It is forced like fire,
a dangerous servant,
a fearful master,
and when you understand that government
is forced and 99 percent of what it does
or doesn't qualify as a
morally justified use of force,
whether it's starting wars are collecting
or beating people up for a plant or
locking them in cages because we
don't like what they're doing.
It's all immoral and we can find
ways to do these things peacefully.
We can find ways without democracy,
without the majority imposing its will
by forcing the minority and using this.
Well we have 51 percent
is a cover so we can,
you know,
we're justified in doing that and,
and that's part of the bigger goal,
you know,
and,
and really this is what,
what I think a lot of people want me
to inspire you to be a part of and to
really see yourself as someone
who was part of the struggle and,
and someone who can see past someone who
has your wisdom to see past the current
paradigm and see that there is
something better on the other side.
Well I think,
like I said,
there's certainly a potential
for something better,
but it's going to have to
come through the youth.
They're going to have to grow up into
the system and change it because it's
changed from the time where people were
wearing white fucking powdered wigs and
they thought the world was
flat and it's going to change.
Is that an hour as well?
What do you mean?
How is it a cop out?
Because I heard,
I heard a review of your podcast saying
that you were like a big brother to a
lot of people that,
that you really serve that role.
I think it's a really powerful one.
I've tried it,
that statement about the evolution of
people figuring out things through the
youth and the youth.
Learning from the mistakes of the what,
what part of that is a cop out because
you're in a position to be a leader.
You don't have.
You don't have to wait for the youth.
I mean,
it's happened.
This sounds like.
What is it?
What is that
dude's name?
Not my.
Not charlie sheen.
What's his brother?
His emilio estevez plot from like 1994.
Um,
what does a leader do?
What I do,
if it inspires people and
they may choose to act,
that's my job to do anything else.
It's not my job to do any thing
else is not what I do best.
It's not what I have in mind when I get
up every day and I wouldn't want to do
it because I wouldn't be happy.
I don't think that everybody has
to be involved in government.
No,
it's inside government is.
Even antigovernment is
the evolution of humanity.
It's what ron paul talks about it
and getting into a voluntary society.
Well,
I would certainly,
and that's why I talk about it as
much as possible on the podcast.
It's my job to inspire and communicate
information and ideas but not delete.
I don't have any desire to do that.
I don't have any desire
to be a part of that,
uh,
have any desire to tell
the people what to do.
I love the idea of being a
leader is disgusting for me,
which is probably what
you need in a leader.
The real problem with leaders
is they want to be leader.
It's about being no,
but see,
you're right.
You're right.
And it's a different kind of
leadership that we're talking about.
And I be the best leader
beCause I would be,
I don't want to be a leader.
I want you should be a fuck.
I hesitate to use that term myself.
You know,
and people try to apply it to me and
I say absolutely not because you know,
I can set an example in a way you'd
better have a good handle on your ego when
you start calling yourself a legal,
a leader.
You.
But that's why.
That's why I don't.
That's why I don't let
myself think of it that way.
So I let you talk about someone involved
at the highest levels of political
office that hasn't done psychedelics.
I'm like,
you are like a little blindfolded child
behind the wheel of a ferrari and you're
going to crash that fucking thing.
You.
You made it all the way to
the very peak of government.
What did you do along
the way that's gross?
You did something.
What'd you do is somebody that committed
suicide by shooting themselves in the
head twice.
It was any of those in your closet.
What the fuck did you do to get here?
Man,
you don't just get here.
You get here,
you're compromised.
Period.
To have them get to that stage of
running things and not having psychedelic
experiences is really kind of childlike.
I think the human being,
but so far as to say who haven't
experienced psychedelics are in a in a
childlike mental state of awareness.
I would never say that about them because
I don't know how they feel about the
world,
but I know for me I was certainly
very childlike before I did the emt.
I was very self centered.
I had a very different perspective
on my place in the universe,
a very different perspective
on my place in humanity,
my place with my friends,
my place that I put everything into
perspective and showed me an illuminated
correct pathway and I think it's by the
humbling experience destroys your ego,
makes you just sit the fuck down and
stopped trying to control everything.
It's like the universe is
really a magical place.
If yOu just absorbed only the
magical aspects of the universe,
you'd be constantly fascinated
every hour of every day.
BuT we forget that and get caught up
and distracted in the horseshit tmz and
nonsense and it's just.
We are still struggling with this fucking
weird primate body that is trying to
figure out how to manage massive
groups of people and insane volumes of
information coming at us all day long.
And that's,
that's where we stand now.
That's,
that's,
that's our conundrum.
Our conundrum is we're,
we're surfing,
but we might not stay on the
board before we hit the rocks.
You know,
we might focus you in on this whole
mother fucker and that's no joke.
You know,
we've just seen a few,
a few interruptions here and there.
One fuck doesn't motivate,
you know,
doesn't that motivate.
Certainly motivates me to live the most
out of my life and motivates me to put
out the most more podcast,
to do more standup comedy,
to have more fun,
to enjoy life,
to enjoy my friends.
It motivates me to do that.
That's what motivates me to.
Yeah,
just I think you have a,
a,
a different track.
You know,
you're on this.
We've got to get shit done,
civil disobedience and go after them.
If you're on this track,
you know,
and to say that like,
I'm a leader and I need to
be a part of that track,
I really don't.
It's not that you need to be.
I'm just inviting you to be.
Oh,
I appreciate it.
It's an I'm not saying
that I'm in any way,
shape or form critical of it.
I'm inviting you to nurture the part
of you that already is on this track.
I would never do that if a
guest asks me to nurture it out,
but it's what you already are.
You already are anti-authoritarian.
You are not anti authoritarian.
What I am is I'm pro nice.
Exactly,
and the real problem with
any sort of authority.
I was a fucking security guard for one
summer at great center for the performing
arts place in mansfield,
Massachusetts.
I got to see fucking amazing bands.
I got to see rodney dangerfield
performed live naked in a bathrobe.
Rodney dangerfield would wear a bathrobe,
and I was.
I was.
Now I feel like I need to take
it about being a comedian man,
and when I.
This is how we'd go on stage.
She would go on stage with a bathrobe on.
He was such a bad motherfucker.
I got to see bill cosby
where I worked there,
but we were at a um,
uh,
what,
what the fuck is his name?
NoT jethro tull,
goddammit.
I can't remember his name.
A southern man.
Neil young,
a neil young concert and
they started fires up in the,
uh,
there was like a,
a wooded area or a brother
or a grassy area at the top.
It was like an amphitheater outside.
And then there was a top area that was
crashed with people decided to start
fires and fucking hell broke loose dude.
And it became an us versus them thing.
It became a us 19 year old kid.
Security guard,
you know,
and my friends who also worked there
against all these people who were neil
young France who were fucked up on drugs
and starting chaos and starting things
on fire.
And I watched like people hit people
that I'd never would have thought would
have hit somebody.
Like my friend larry
was one of the nicest,
most peace loving guys.
And I watched him punch this
dude in the stomach and I'm like,
well,
I can't believe larry just hit that guy.
I was like,
I gotta get the fuck outta here.
But it was an immediate us versus
them thing that happens when you.
It becomes a real problem
if you're not educated,
right?
If you work in any position
of authority and position of,
you know,
we,
you're going to have some control and
be able to tell people and to build,
you've got to work compassionate to
that because when you don't have that,
when you lose that,
that,
that we're all in this together,
then you're not a cop man.
You're the fucking enemy like that.
You saw that video in,
in long beach where that kid is
lying down and they step on his head.
Did you see that thomas,
the one that died in the hospital?
No,
no,
no.
He didn't die.
The kid,
the kid who was in a,
uh,
long beach medical marijuana dispensary,
the cops came in and
stepped on.
The guy is a real,
really recent radio.
You might notice it,
but anybody who would
do something like that,
you get a peaceful person
who's just lying down.
Pathological,
pathological.
It's the same thing as
what government is it?
It's the same thing that chimps would
do if they could do that to other chips.
It's fucking primal.
It's prime.
Oh,
ridiculous.
Selfish behavior and that's.
That's what really needs to be eradicated.
We need to figure out a
way to connect people.
That's what this.
But that's what this is about.
That's what this movement is about.
That's what.
That's what the revolution.
What is the revenue load is the movement.
This was star wars revolution.
The revolution.
You know how you you.
You saw the ron Paul Love
evolution where it's,
it's revolutionary that evil is backwards.
So it says love.
Yes.
That's how we
say the revolution,
and really that's what it's about.
It's about embracing the,
the divinity of every human being and,
and,
and treating every human
being with the love,
faith and respect that
we want for ourselves,
and we're coming to the point where
we're realizing this anyways because the
market favors cooperation.
The market favors that.
People who are able to get along or
able to be more prosperous aren't,
you know,
able to out reproduce
outcompete the ones that aren't.
And so It's kind of happening anyways,
but what's exciting and,
and I,
and really this is why I don't want,
I'm not here to tell you like
you have an obligation to do this.
Like you,
if you don't vote,
you're an irresponsible citizen.
It's not that bullshit.
It's just that this is something that
motivates me in the same way that you have
a similar motivation,
you know.
And um,
I'm the oldest of five brothers.
It's adam,
andrew,
alex aldean and andrea my,
my dad has a big white suburban,
the license plates as 18.
So,
you know,
and for some of them I was more like
a crazy uncle than a big brother.
But this review that I read
of your podcast was describing
you as big brother to
your audience.
And I think in that capacity,
being able to
share,
uh,
this vision at least and,
and well,
I think the problem is when you
start calling to revolution,
first of all,
because then people could sell illusion
because it's an evolution grandizing is
that what we agreed becomes that it
becomes that you call it whatever love,
aleutian.
It's a,
you,
you define yourself as a movement.
This is come join the movement.
I'm not already in the movement.
I think you already are.
How my joint things,
you know what I'm saying,
but you know what I'm saying.
Like all of a sudden like,
okay,
I'm in.
Well,
you know,
then then we become a move out.
Self identification.
Yeah.
I don't think that's necessary.
I think what we are is human beings
that understand that our system is not
correct and to call
ourselves a revolution,
to call ourselves anything
other than just human beings.
I think it's pointless.
I think it's rational thinking.
Human beings.
It realize there's something wrong here.
And that includes the people in
the system that includes cops,
that includes judges,
that includes lawyers,
that includes everybody along the line
that it's all equally eligible for
personal awakening.
Every single one of them with the proper
medication and the right setting could
see some shit that would make them rethink
reality and it would make them humble
enough to at least understand that they
don't know everything because they never
knew that that was there.
You can say,
you know everything.
I'm a fucking smart guy.
I was in my class.
I get you high on dmt.
I guarantee you,
you will think about everything different
for the rest of your life because you
didn't know that was there.
You didn't know that all you had to do
was follow a few simple steps and you're
in a different land where
everything is complex.
Geometric patterns made out of
love and understanding that,
uh,
communicating with you in some sort of
a telekinetic language or telekinesis
language,
I don't think that you
can really appreciate life
unless you know that that's
there.
If you don't know that that's there.
It's like you've lived three quarters
of a life like you don't understand,
there's there's an is an experience
and it only takes about 15 minutes and
you'll never be the same again,
but you're going to come back and you're
going to be burdened with all your past
preconceived notions and ideas and all
the things that you've learned from your
life,
but you're essentially going to
be a totally different person.
Now you're a person who can never Forget
the things that you saw or the way that
you felt when you experienced that.
Now,
whether that's just your brain getting
tweaked with chemicals or whether it
really is what it feels like because
what it feels like is you're going to
another place and we just assumed that
the only way to travel is to put one foot
in front of the other,
getting a car,
getting a plane with them.
you might be able to travel chemically
between dimensions and that might be what
things like dmt are all about.
That might be why it's made
by your own fucking brain.
Well,
we should make.
That's why I probably just started sort
of started this conversatIon by saying,
hey,
welcome to this thing that
we're describing as a movement
now because your deal,
man,
I'm being super hyper
critical for no reason,
but you're,
you're already a part of this and I,
and,
and you know,
the reason that so many people in
my audience really appreciated this
conversation and like era
anticipated it is because they,
they,
they realize that you already carry this
message in a way very powerfully in the
way that you talk about society
and the way that you integrate it.
And what would I just want to do
is that he does want to express my
appreciation.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
but I think everybody does now.
I think we've reached a point
where I think reached a point.
We're going to melt.
It's the fucking ac down there fixing her.
oh,
so they shut it off.
Sons pitches a good.
We feel the heat of suppression that
mother earth gives us and this oppression
will help us get through
this podcast better.
Um,
look,
man,
I think everybody's recognizing it now.
AnYbody with a brain is realizing,
you know,
bush was the first guy where
everybody had to step back and go,
wow,
like because of the access to information,
that was the first time we got real news,
daily news online and shit.
There was the first time
people realize like,
whoa,
this is,
this administration is
bought and paid for like,
this is ridiculous.
Like this is the most obviously bought
and paid like they're rocking it in a way
that nobody had previously done.
Everybody had been way slicker about
hiding their connections to money into war
profiteering,
but the bush administration
just let their freak flag fly.
They just fucking went out,
started to wars.
That made no sense.
Profited a fuck load of money.
if you could talk to George Bush,
what would that conversation be like?
If you could just get
a loan with that guy,
would you do it respectfully?
Would you slowly try to chip away at
it and try to get his perspective?
Or do you think you would just lose your
fucking mind when you were just in the
face of someone who is at least indirectly
responsible for the death of probably
a million people and from
my own ptsd in a sense?
Yeah,
sure.
And what would that be like
to be in front of that guy?
That's a great question.
You know,
and I,
and I used to,
when I was active with Iraq
veterans against the war,
when I got out of the marines and was
disgruntled and started questioning
things,
I used to fantasize about that,
like a physical violent
guy punch him in the face.
I don't think you should
say that on the radio.
well this was like George Bush.
you know what?
I think you can threaten them.
A past president.
I think you faked do that.
No,
but is that funny?
They get arrested for that.
I know I've,
I've had experiences but
now you feel differently.
Well,
yeah.
I think part of my own philosophical
development and my own experience going
through to the point where
I feel like I got to,
you know,
you never get all the way to the bottom,
but like to the effective bottom
of the rabbit hole for me where I,
that allows me to function the
way that I do now with the,
my current understanding of the world.
You know,
part of It was having a
philosophical approach.
There's a quote from a buddhist monk,
thich nhat hahn,
I'm sure I'm butchering the name,
but it's something like when
someone does harm to you,
it is only because harm has been done
to them and they are reflecting it back
and they are expressing and,
and,
and to me,
I see that that is what government
as a whole is in the sense that it's
pathological behavior.
It is a relic of human evolution,
of the scarring of the.
The only way we were able to raise kids
in the state of nature was you'll beat
them.
So they keep up with the tribe and
the evolution of that into government.
And I see that as a George Bush,
simply a representation of that broader
social phenomenon of government being
the last manifestation of this desire
to control and dominate and use violence
against others.
And so it,
You know,
and it's not that the president
is a pitch man or a puppet,
he's a power broker,
you know,
he legitimately makes decisions,
but the reason,
the one who usually gets into
the position as the one that is,
is because he's reflective of the
environment that produces them.
And that's the existing power structure.
And that's the paradigm
of society as a whole.
And that's why changing the paradigm
and waking people up and the perspective
that you share about government is
so powerful because what ultimately
determines whether or not you are going
to be free is whether the human beings
around you agree that you should be
free and they won't tolerate people
initiating force against you
when you're acting peacefully.
So the only way to do that
is to make them happier.
That's,
that's the real trick,
to get them to lighten the fuck up.
Things are not that bad.
You know,
you really look in perspective,
things are not that Bad,
but one of my biggest philosophical
influences is stefan molyneux and he went
through a whole process of
describing this anarcho,
capitalist,
ideal society and,
and really to embrace this philosophy,
you kind of have to go through all of
the resistances that people have like
without government,
who's going to build the roads,
you know,
and it's the same question as,
as people would ask when we were
trying to abolish slavery and it was,
but without the slaves,
who's going to pick the content?
Is anything wrong with
having a form of council,
you know,
the idea of calling them
government and like,
like what the obama
administration was able to do,
what the obama administration was able
to do in this whole operation fast and
furious.
Or hE was able to,
you know,
just say I don't want to
talk about it and why,
what does it invoking executive
order or whatever executive privilege.
I mean,
how silly is that?
You just let it.
There's a giant scandal where they sold
guns to mexican drug dealers and they
said,
oh yeah,
yeah,
we're just going to track them.
One of those guns justify getting hold.
One of those guns killed
one of the petroleum.
Yeah,
like the idea that he would be able to
use executive privilege and get out of
that and to do it so blatantly like that.
That's a creepy thing.
Like you can't have things like that.
That's what I'm saying.
That kind of shit like that,
but that's what I'm saying.
Like in accounting for of council,
that would never exist in
a form of dictatorship.
That's where something like
that to get out of jail free.
It's what do you think that you need
government to accomplish and how you do it
instead of having an arbitrage?
We'd like leaders and the lead,
but I think the leadership,
the anti political,
it's anti leaders.
It's,
it's,
it's anti-authoritarian.
It's saying we're not going to
allow ourselves to be cowed.
We are going to understand that as
human beings and what we call the free
market,
we are able to cooperatively accomplish
all the things that we've been convinced
we need government for.
Right?
I understand that,
but someone's gonna have
to execute decision.
Someone's gonna have to
put things in motion.
He going to have to a group code examples.
what is the thing that needs to get done,
whether you know it might
not have a consensus of how
many cops need to be hired
as opposed to how many teachers need to
be hired and how much they should get
people paying for those services.
How do they do that?
They do that wIth a form of government.
They get together,
they have council,
they do it through corporations.
They do it through companies where they
able to buy protection services where
they're able to get the the the legitimate
services that police provide without
forcing it on people just because
they happen to even teachers meet.
Even deciding what salaries are you
going to have to have some sort of a way
that people can interact with each other
and someone's going to have to execute
it.
That's called the free market,
but that person who executes it should
be someone who respected council,
someone who knows you.
Take advantage of the fact that why
are people doing their jobs jobs,
the ceo of apple.
Why?
What book?
What made steve jobs the ceo of apple,
very creatIve guy started
off market forces.
He was the most valuable one to be in
the command of those market resources,
so you want to turn the government
and how things run into it.
Just a big free market as far as police,
as far as teachers,
everything's just a giant freedom.
I want to take the violence out of.
I don't want to take the coercion now.
You don't want it to be accomplished
peacefully by people cooperating.
Instead of saying,
oh,
well,
you live here,
you're going to pay these taxes.
Oh,
well,
you live here.
You're going to be under someone's gonna.
Have to organize how the
hospital gets kept up.
Is that going to be a public
thing or is that going to be.
I mean you opposed to everything will
look at how much more public space station
are you opposed to public.
I'm opposed to education
that's funded by violence.
How was it founded?
By allowance?
What do you mean by that?
You think a child going to school doesn't
understand that if they don't go to
school everyday,
their parents get in trouble and that
the way the school is paid for by taxes
that the parents pay against their will.
Whether or not they have
children in a school system,
children get that.
They understand that we grow up,
but this is this.
This is the status,
but that's one way way of looking at it.
It's also true that parents pay taxes
in a very specific neighborhood because
they know there's a good school system
in there and then they run rallies for
the school system and they gather up
money and people don't,
and so that's also true.
I see that and so that in
community schools as well,
that it's not always negative.
Okay.
That aspect of it,
however,
is superior.
Is it not to the federal department of
education coming into that community and
st now you're going to follow these
testing standards in order to get these
funds and if you don't
do what we say with this.
So I'm all.
I'm saying it's nice
that a careful community.
Yes.
You see that difference.
So that community should be
determined not by people.
I mean,
what do you.
How is this,
how is the money paying the teachers?
How is that coming from violence?
I don't understand.
How do you pay taxes?
What happens?
What happens if you don't pay taxes?
We're not contributing to society.
I mean I don't think we should.
Tax says we are not contributing
to wider to corruption.
That is true.
So it's.
So do you think that all taxes are bad?
Do you think that we should have no taxes?
Taxes are a moral.
All taxes are moral.
So how do we expect to
pay for the city streets?
How do we expect to pay to
maintain some sort of a,
a,
a presence with police officers
and fund them with cars?
Is it all just donations?
No,
it will.
This is the difference between what we
have with government and what we already
have in the free market.
Do people pay for protection?
Then?
Does it become you can do it.
The community.
That sounds like a good idea.
You can do it.
The private cops that decided to not
save you because you didn't pay for
protection.
The differences with them
all You get is protection.
Whereas with the police today,
do we get protection?
Sometimes you do.
No,
that's not true.
Good cops.
There's,
there's,
there's good cops out there.
Okay.
Well what is not all bad?
All cops are not bad.
Just because some cops do a bunch of
stupid shit and those guys in the video
with you are clearly bad.
Okay,
so wouldN't.
This is the mechanism
by which you separate.
The good cops are on the bad cops.
There are the ones.
No,
no.
This is the mechanism by which you
actually do it is you take the arbitrary
power of government away from them.
You make them serve the market.
You make them serve the people peacefully.
You make them convince you that
their services are necessary,
not put a gun to your head and say,
if you don't pay our taxes,
you're going to get locked in a cage.
Well,
I think that locking someone in jail
for taxes is very unfortunate and it
doesn't make sense when you think about
how many fucking gigantic corporations
have gone bankrupt and how
much more that affected people.
Then You know one person who's not paying
the little tiny slice of the military
industrial complex is pie,
but you should have to pay something.
It should make sense that you're getting
something out of it and you should want
to contribute.
I live in a community and if everybody,
if everybody said,
well,
hey man,
our streets are all fucked up,
but it mike gathered up all the names.
Everybody lives here and realize
if we all just chip in $100,
we could fix this whole thing.
I think it's worth it for me for $100 gun.
And everybody goes,
yeah,
that would be beautiful.
I'm talking about government.
That's great.
That's exactly.
The technology allows us all the way.
They didn't have jobs if we
didn't have responsibility,
children,
careers,
if we didn't have things we
had to think about all day.
Instead you're running around out
there trying to figure out how to pay
the firemen and how to make sure that
the cop tires are good and you know,
at a certain point in time,
how much micromanagement can
you do in your community.
Why w w,
how is it for cable now?
Internet,
tv and your in your,
in your,
in your house.
How is it that you get
that without government?
Uh,
so you.
But you proposed that for things
that we think of as civil services,
right?
And he proposed that for like,
cops will look at it.
I just seen that kills tricky man hops.
That's mercenaries.
Think about what the fuck is going on.
And I ran right now the
problem with mercenaries is
that they do things that the
government funds them to do.
That the market would never support.
That ties.
People only won't only want
cops to do legitimate things.
The only way that you have mercenaries
doing things that are immoral is because
it's funded by government
in the first place.
okay.
I can see that argued easily.
Um,
if,
if tHey don't have a specific set of
rules and are only open to the market,
they're going to push as far as they
possibly can to get things done.
And if they're dealing with
businesses that have a lot of money,
they're going to do
things that aren't legal.
But that's what would happen if you
privatize the cops and that's a fact.
That's just how human beings are.
If you give them little loopholes and
you allow them to figure out how to get
through those loopholes,
they're like rats on a sinking ship and
they're going to pop out and they're
going to fuck things up.
No,
because the only,
you're,
you're basing that on an understanding
of the corporate structure of the current
government paradigm where government
empowers corporations to have an unnatural
advantage in the market and
protect them from competition.
So cops,
man,
hold on.
No,
no.
In your scenario,
you say,
rich people like existing corporations
and concentrations of wealth would abuse
this ability to hire police forces and
private whatever to be able to do evil
things.
Well,
guess what?
They already can.
The thing iS what we have is a government
that keeps the rest of us from doing
the same thing.
From being able to say that our
demands for community safety services,
our demands are being met by the market,
not by a monopoly that's forced on us.
This is why this is the
premise of the drug war man.
You do this.
The drug war goes away.
All unjust laws go away
because the demands on the
enforcers are the demands of
the market there.
What people actually want.
The bad cops go away because
you get to fiRe them.
There's no police unions that say you
can't fire people and there's going to be
a law against this that
if a cop shoots somebody,
he's going to get paid leave.
You know that kind of bullshit.
All of that goes away when you have roads.
Like I was telling you the way that
they're holding us back from technological
development,
but specifically like in New Mexico where
the speaker of the house gets to just
say,
well,
put that intersection by my land.
so the value of it goes up.
All of that goes away.
And to say that,
well,
we need corruption goes away.
Yes.
How does corruption go away?
Because it's in order to make money in
the free market and this is the free
market.
Makes corruption go with will.
Hold on a second.
The,
the,
the capitalist ideal is
that it's free individuals,
multiple parties are able to engage
in trade because it mutual is a mutual
benefit,
right?
I,
you know,
I give you something,
you give me something.
We both believe that
we're better off from it.
This is the basic concept of capitalism,
of free trade,
of application of yourself as a capital
resource engaged in the free market and
anytime you introduce coercion into that,
you take away from our ideal
potential as humanity to engage
in commerce.
No argument with that.
So that's what government does.
And so if you had,
if you had the ability now
is we do technologically
obviously to pool resources
to come.
You're saying you're calling government,
you're,
you're defining human
nature as government.
You're saying anybody with power,
you defining that as government?
No,
I'm just saying that would happen
in your private top system too,
right?
Right.
No,
probably wouldn't work.
Right?
What I'm saying is that government is
the current manifestation of human desire
to control and dominate others by forest.
This is the preMise.
So that's the only way to
govern what you're saying.
Well,
the only way to cover this definition
of governing and without that it's
impossible to have like a
compassionate leadership.
It's impossible.
No,
with that you have cooperation,
you have leadership of people
that are doing good work.
So that's a government know.
What is the leadership then if there's,
if there's a leadership that
you've got a government,
if you've got someone who's leading,
you've got a government.
So you've got another government,
you got to benevolent government.
Steve jobs was in a leader
in the technological field.
I think steve jobs was a general of apple.
Absolutely.
So was he,
was he government?
Yes.
Absolute jobs.
Was government for sure.
If you were involved with that,
finding government involved with
apple and you left your phone,
uh,
you the prototype phone
in a bar somewhere,
even though it's awesome.
Free publicity that you
would be arrested or you,
you would,
they would for sure they check the guy.
They fucking storm troopers
house with machine guns.
Looked everywhere for the iphone then
that mean is that not like government
would do?
That's exactly what the
government would do.
And then they fire the guy.
That's exactly what the
government would do.
Yeah.
So I'd say steve jobs was the government.
Okay,
well then then we're,
we're still sort of talking about.
And that is a corporation.
I mean that is the real free market.
I mean the corporation
is the village of apple.
Okay.
But you're throwing up
these objections that are,
that are just objections
are totally not objective.
These are all,
this is all just a devil's advocate,
but then it's an,
it's an important thing to say.
but like I said,
when when you were living
under slavery and someone said,
hey,
we need to end slavery.
The,
the,
the devil's advocate was saying,
but who's going to pick the cotton?
And the answer is,
it may understand.
I'm not saying that you should
have an oppressive government.
I'm saying can't we have people that we
really love and respect real leaders?
Because if you look at a
guy like bill clinton now,
now that he stopped chasing
tail and everything,
you know,
you think he stopped,
he think he stops.
He'll think.
So imagine those,
those girls and their hard drives,
clinton picks.
If they wouldn't stop there,
be clinton dick pics,
man.
Don't you think there'll
be worth so much money?
How can the girls keep your mouth shut?
do you know how many
people clinton is killed?
I wonder how many people clinton's killed.
You think he's filled?
A lot of people know,
but I think after you suck his dick,
you get a little briefing.
Do you think that.
Did you ever read the strange
death of vince foster?
You know,
the story that guy,
it's one of the guys involved.
And somehoW or another he had some sort
of connection to that giant real estate
deal that the clintons were
involved in were fucking this.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about there.
There was a guy that went around
that had this list of 70 people that
mysteriously died around.
The clinton family might
just be how things are done.
It might just be how at a
certain point in government,
everybody just knows
that's how shit's done.
And it's always been that way.
And you know,
here's the zapruder film.
I mean it's just,
oh,
he's been that way.
It seems like.
I mean,
you don't bomb out all the
things that obama said.
You know,
you think about the stores
of obama being in Hawaii,
smoking pot with his friends.
His friends had.
obama would go interception step.
They don't take the joint.
It would asshole fat stoner.
Yeah.
What was the news that obama was a star?
He was an asshole.
Stoner.
Yeah.
I mean,
unless everybody's already high.
And it's just funny.
It's kind of funny.
It could be an inside job.
If everybody's already baked
and you just pointlessly court.
He's the guy always buying the weed,
you know,
and it's like,
I'm a heavyweight,
I'm going to buy the weed.
So,
or it can be a selfish dick asshole
power broker who's murdering people as a
president of the United States.
It was a strange time when obama won
the nobel peace prize and then they sent
30,000 more people to Afghanistan,
like a boiler
change.
It was so strange.
It was like,
wow,
this is the part in the
movie where you got go,
what the fuck?
You know,
this is a part of the movie to watch,
but it's like an episode of a giant,
giant episode of the watchman if like
they continued to make the series.
Did you see the,
uh,
the watchman?
You don't watch any moviEs,
man.
You know what?
It moved from the cultural loop.
What do you make it fun?
I watched documentaries.
That's where you get your fun.
Really.
Like I said,
I go to the gym,
I go to,
I go to mma,
that's fine.
I run with my dog,
I go,
I go to wholefoods,
I go to target when I need to,
and I'm in my apartment.
I'm a total homebody.
And you just working constantly
making videos in the prize.
Yeah,
that's good man.
but kind of have some fun in this life.
It is,
is.
Do you ever go to olive garden?
Know brian,
you kid to,
to all gardenIng in one episode.
You're overdoing yourself.
You're becoming a parody
of your own creation.
Stop it.
Stop before you ruin this
fucking beautiful show.
Um,
I'm totally not disagreeing
with you by the way.
When we talked about anything,
It's just I just,
uh,
I'm a devil's advocate sort of a guy
and I think the effort explore whenever
someone gives me absolute,
that's when I automatically go,
oh,
what about this?
And it's not that I'm,
you know,
and people will argue with
me on twitter and I'm like,
I agree with you too.
I'm not,
I'm not committed to any version of
the future that I think is going to be
optimum,
but I'm not averse to the idea that
someone could be in a position where they
could benevolently guide people instead
of the idea of run us like a government,
you know,
and be able to be involved in some sort
of fucking crazy gun running scheme and
evoke executive privilege where you
don't have to talk about the crazy gun
running scheme that they sold guns to
mexican drug dealers and one of them
killed the us federal agent.
You don't have to talk about that.
Not in my vision of what's possible.
I think you have to be accountable
for all your information.
You have to be accountable for all
your duties and it should be a place of
benevolence.
I don't think that's possible,
man with technology too is
happening with your podcast.
I'm sure it's happening with this pot.
No,
no,
no.
I mean in a real simple mechanical sense,
the way that technology is empowering,
you know,
google glasses,
pretty soon we're going to have facial
recognition embedded in contact lenses.
Right?
And to the extent that you want
to make your information public,
you'll people will be able to scan your
face and see your reputation and it'll
be your rep.
There'll be some way of
accounting for your reputation,
be allegedly that pops up.
If people want to see that
your yelp score stars,
you're going to be able to like we're
all in that laser thing that they have at
the tsa agents checkpoints now where
they shoot the laser and read all your
shit.
You're going to have that
embedded in your glasses.
It's all going to be a part of
this system of accountability.
And it's weird because you know everybody
should be uncomfortable about how
privacy is going away,
but if anything,
you get the government out of it and you
decide what your level of invasiveness
is.
And that's what's so cool
about this technology,
empowering people to do things that we
think we need government for that we
really don't.
And it's now with the technology
as superfluous as it is,
it's,
it's easy to see it.
You can see it coming.
I see What you're saying.
what you're saying is that people are
going to have to act together and instead
of government they're going to have to
form some sort of a sense of community.
It's just really hard to do that
when the numbers are so big.
We're just not designed to deal and be
able to manage hundreds of millions of
people when one person
is in charge of that,
it's almost ridicuLous.
Well,
who's in charge of the internet?
You know that's the high though.
That's where it's happening.
That's what's beautiful,
but the internet paradigm is shifting
right now at least can't really make
physical things.
You know,
a manifest themselves as easily
as a group of people can.
Well,
our civil disobedience beach party,
that was a group of people breaking laws
and standing up to the man the other
day happened on 24 hour notice because
I got a facebook and a twitter account.
Right?
Well you dug holes and
start.
it's a start.
We're working on the tax revolt for
when obamacare is fully implemented.
You know,
but like this is,
this is how you start is by
celebrating civil disobedience.
And second is the
conversations that you've,
um,
you started on this podcast
and the topics that you,
you're so passionate about.
This is really how it starts because now
there's some dude right now that is on
the train,
on his way to work and he listens to this
podcast every day and these ideas are
imprinting in his head and they're
helping him or influencing him in his
decision and what he's
going to do witH his future.
And that's where I think
everything is starting.
I think everything right now,
what we're seeing as far as the changing
of the world is nothing compared to the
people that are growing up with
the internet from baby to grown up.
Because that's a totally different.
They're not gonna.
You're not gonna be able to
sell them donald rumsfeld.
Bullshit.
You're not gonna be able to sell
though dewey decimal system,
horse shit.
no.
They're going to google
and know on a fucking note,
it looks like a laptop,
but it fits in your pocket.
You can fucking say,
man,
these other kids that are their teachers
and calling them on their bullshit
because they,
they,
they know that public schools are
government run indoctrination centers.
You know,
you saw that,
that made headlInes.
Ignore all those schools are just
cheap as fuck as what they are.
They have no money and everybody suck.
What is the purpose they
serve to government,
man?
No,
it's more than that.
There's a reason government
has taken over education.
It's.
This is the dumbing down.
You look at the federal department
of education instituted like what?
Forty,
50 years ago when we were at or near the
top of every international educational
ranking system.
Now we're down like 30,
40.
It's not by accident.
It's by design.
What I've seen to be dumbed down
and not question government.
They want to control the curriculum so
you don't learn about topics like what
we're talking about now.
This is why they don't teach real history.
They've been.
Who is thinking,
man,
this is the real problem with that.
I think it's more incompetent.
No,
you're right.
No incontinent product of the paradigm.
People don't benefit and profit
from making the schools better,
so it's easy to keep them suppressed.
It's not that there's some sort of a
strategy to try to keep people stupid.
It's that there's no money to
be made for making people smart.
So why should they try
so they don't trust.
So tHe underfunded schools,
so when things get cut,
cut the fucking teachers
pay for fuck math suck.
My dick cut her pay.
So that's what we need
to balance the budget,
which we do.
Cut the school no more wrestling
and that's where it's coming from.
It's not coming from some fucking
grand poobah plot with as much assholes
standing in the middle of
a field burning in effigy,
deciding how people stupid,
incompetent.
It's incompetent conspiracy.
What can be described by incumbents?
Comments?
I learned that from work,
especially with government,
government workers,
right?
Government fucking workers.
That's the.
That is the tap out job of all time.
you're like,
I'm not.
I got no ambition,
man.
You know what I gotta do you
know what you want me to do?
This is the reason and
it's not by accident.
The first thing they cut from the
curriculum is your ability to see what is
happening.
What is that?
What's going to help you?
They don't shit teachers to folks.
They don't teach.
Well the august,
they don't teach cIvics anymore.
He put you in a room with a teenage kid.
That's a nice guy.
And uh,
when a water put you in
a room and a teenage kid,
that's a nice guy and he lets test,
tells you to go to all
his favorite websites.
Can you guys just go to websites
all day and you learn shit?
Now look at the cnn.
Look at this.
This is a story right here.
This is how the egyptian
god got in government.
I hear this now you go
like this and you find out.
Well they were actually worse off with
the new government in Egypt because
they're even more crazy.
The muslim brotherhood.
Oh shit.
I mean you can get more education and
have a couple of hours with a curious
person and a computer then you
can out of most school day.
Well,
this is one of the things that that's
happening in America right now.
This will we call the libertarian mind
melt and It's kind of a phenomenon we see
people going through.
We used to joke like,
what's the dIfference between a
minnaar kissed and an anarchist?
You know,
someone who kissed someone who
believes in government limited to the
constitution or to specific principles,
you know,
the government should only be used for
this or that as opposed to really we
should evolve past government
and that expression.
A menard kissed.
How are you spelling it?
Am I on?
I'm on invest.
Minimal.
That's exactly.
And ron paul is often
confused as them in our case,
you know,
he's,
he,
he presents a monarch is
platform as an immediate
practical transition of going
back to the constitution
or at least getting government
restrained to what it's,
you know,
legally authorized to do supposedly.
And his,
his end goal though is
a volunteer society.
And when I interviewed him for my tv show,
we talked about this and he
says that he is a volunteer.
It's all human interaction
should be free of force,
fraud and coercion.
And when,
when,
when you really get that,
you know you're,
you're okay saying I don't know,
when you look to the future
and you're okay saying law,
when we don't have slavery,
I don't know who's going to pick the con.
I don't know if we're going to have big
machines that do that are going to pick,
pick the cotton for us and then spit out
t shirts like we don't know how that's
gonna happen and who's
going to build the roads.
We don't know what's the exact system
that the market is going to be able to do.
Who's going to do it?
People are going to do it.
People are gonna do it peacefully.
And when you understand that government
is not going to be potholes everywhere
and nothing is ever going
to get to that part,
lazy bitches,
they're gonna show up late half ass day.
The hospital's going to smell
like armpits and listen man,
I don't know.
People are ready for that yet.
I see what you're saying.
we both want improvement.
I see whaT you're saying.
I don't know if I'm
married your system though,
man.
I don't know if I'm married
to this crazy people.
People use,
people will go system,
people are,
are,
are going through this
and and in the course of.
I mean we've,
we've been talking for a few hours.
Then of course if a conversation,
it's very hard for someone
to really shed their,
their attachment to violence
because that's what it is.
YOu have an comparing violence though the
government doesn't necessarily have to
be violent if it evolves
in the council 10 minutes,
you just got the 10 minute warning at
three hours are fucking thing becomes a
pumpkin.
Oh,
we're done.
Well that's the definition
will of government.
It's all backed up by force,
but I know that that is an option,
but I don't necessarily believe that the
idea is that everything you're doing,
you're doing the threat of violence,
so we're just using different terms of
threat of violence is only there for
people that don't want to subscribe
to the standards of the community.
I'm doing whAt I'm saying.
I'm defining government as the
use of violence in that sense.
So you're just,
you're just,
you just have a broader
sense of what government is.
Only the use of violence.
If things go wrong,
it's not the use of violence or if
someone disagrees with the majority,
that's just shit cops.
It's just shit that anybody who
doesn't want to pay for wars,
you can protest all you want as
long as you keep paying your taxes,
they'll still be a war.
Right?
I see what you're saying that your
money's going to go to that anyway.
But what would be a beautiful thing if
you were able to vote whether or not your
money went to the war,
boy,
would award be different than if you could
like check off of what someone should
introduce that they should say you get
to vote whether or not any of your tax
dollars ever get you anything.
Military has to be road worldwide.
Yep.
And you'd be like,
fuck you.
If you could actually decide
to pay less taxes or more tags.
What I'm advocating,
that's exactly what I'm advocating in war.
The wars would be really small,
just like cold up fights between
a couple of extra dollar.
Just so keep me safe.
ExactlY.
Be free,
free to watch people drive
around in a circle.
Listen,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to get through this.
I don't know if it's going to be the adam
call cash model or if it's going to be
the terence mckenna mayan apocalypse,
2012 model.
I don't know what the
fuck's going to happen,
but we're going to get through this too.
Man.
I feel really bad now.
I spent time answering your questions
and talking about why do that.
I always,
because I wanted to ask you,
I wanted.
I wanted you to.
I want to get Your your mentorship and
tap your wisdom and see about what you
think I should be doing differently
because you're not listening to anything
that you're doing what you want to do,
and I think what you want
to do is educate people,
enlightened people,
express information,
and I think that's a beautiful thing.
That's why you're so happy.
You're happy because you're
genuinely doing good things.
You're happy because you're genuinely
affecting people in a positive way.
You're putting out a positive blast
of energy and information and allowing
people to empower their thoughts
and allow people to realize that,
hey man,
I'm not crazy.
I'm a nice person.
There's other people like that out there.
There's other people that believe
in truth and what real liberty is.
Liberty is having the liberty to do
what you want and we're not affecting
people.
Having the ability to roam
anywhere unrestricted.
You don't have to be fucked
with by someone that is
just there because there's a
job opening and that job
opening is controlled.
People enforce this shit that's
written down on this piece of paper,
so you're doing great already.
Well,
that's exactly what talking.
Keep.
Keep on doing what you're doing,
man.
Just do what you're doing.
That's what I'm going to do
and that's what brian does.
We know what the right thing to do is,
man,
we all have an internal compass
is telling you what to do.
She's got to figure out a way to avoid
all the pitfalls in life that can keep
you from accomplishing that
are going in that direction.
Everybody's is different.
You just got to find it.
You dirty bitches.
This is not a fucking self help show.
What have you done to debate?
Do.
Thank you very much.
We talked about masturbating
for like an hour an hour.
Well,
that's,
that's a good amount of time to take off
if you ever want to come back and do it
again,
man.
Let's do it again.
Do it again in the future.
If you're ever in la,
les again,
and now that you're a
legal medical patients,
I'm sure you have to come
back and get medicated.
I'm thank You everybody for
tuning in and thank you adam.
Coke cash.
Please watch his podcast.
Adam versus the man.com versus
the [inaudible] dot com.
Follow him on twitter.
Adam,
coke k o k e s h on twitter.
Brian redman,
please follow him.
Red b,
a n follow alien ware.
Mma just for a goof.
Follow cto coconut water.
TheY're the shit and nice people and
go ahead and follow the fleshlight.
You freak.
Do whatever the fuck you want.
Thank you to [inaudible] dot com.
Go to a o n n I t a.
Use the code named brogan and save
yourself 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
We've got a show tonight at the ice house.
It's going down in about
two hours and 20 minutes,
ladies and gentlemen.
and it will be done by
rare greg fitzsimmons.
Uh,
ari shaffir brian red band,
ico,
tanaka.
Brian murphy,
tony hinchcliffe,
hInchcliffe.
and me and our san diego
shows sold out friday.
The first winners.
A few more tickets left in thursday.
There's a few more tickets left.
So there's more than one show on friday.
Yeah,
there's two shows.
What time of day?
I think 8:30 and 10:30.
I got two shows friday in san diego.
Last gentleman's comedy company,
one of them's already sold out.
So come on down.
You dirty freaks.
This is my first experience at comic con
and if you're listening to New Jersey,
we have another civil
disobedience swimsuit protests
on the boardwalk in asbury
park this saturday,
July 14th.
You're not allowed to wear
swimsuits on the boardwalk.
It's punishable by a thousand dollars.
Five days in jail.
What kind of content is this?
We're standing up to the man that is
not a cop that is a glorified revenue
collector.
That is sometimes so is that a piss poor
job of managing that fucking community?
It might be just because they don't want
girls with thongs around little kids
that are on the pier.
Why let them learn young to see that?
Take a good look.
Right and haven.
I gotta get one more plug in if I'm to
sperm veterans for ron paul who are so
inspired like I am by his message
to be on this philosophical journey.
We're going to be marching
on the rnc in tampa.
August 27th.
Be there for paul fez.
Hold on.
You just say you're going to march
outside in tampa in fucking august.
Eight miles preposterous.
I was in fallujah.
What do you expect?
That's crazy,
man.
You got to kill some old people.
We're going to go salute ron paul because
he's woken so many people up there.
Drive air,
air conditioning and shit.
Maybe we'll wave a flag out the window.
You can drive and meet us
there just to get a tattoo.
we're going to salute ron paul.
I'm not walking outside side.
Listen,
ladies and gentlemen,
this fucking podcast is over.
Thank you to adam call cash.
Thank you very much.
There's a lot of fun,
man.
Like I said,
we'll do it again,
brother.
Absolutely.
For sure.
And if you ever need
anything you know tweeted,
you want to let people know,
let us know.
Yeah,
spread the information revolution.com.
Go get.
Get yourself some kettlebells.
He's dirty bitches and
some fucking battle ropes.
Get all manly.
Alright,
we will see next week.
We've got a lot of people coming up soon.
We've got a kat von d and I are in
talks of doing a podcast next week.
It'll be kevin smith's podcast.
I'll let you know.
We're working that out.
You guys are giving me a hard time for
hitting on the wheat chick on the air.
You guys are talking to porn stars.
Kat von d's are poor.
So she's a tattoo artist.
Oh my bad.
I've been.
I'm talking about brian earlier.
What are you talking?
Oh yeah,
well they're his friends actually.
He has.
He does podcasts with them.
He's actually doing a podcast.
Tara patrick rather show it Sarah Patrick,
saturday night at 90
show at the same club.
American comedy co.com.
Desk squad.
That team and solar than me.
Oh,
this is nothing cool about that.
All right folks,
thanks for all the love.
I can't say it any more
succinctly clearly than that.
Thanks for everything.
Thanks for the twitter messages.
Thanks for all the positive energy.
Thanks for basically
being a part of all this.
I don't even know what the fuck this is,
but something's going down
the love aleutian strap in.
I don't think it's that.
I think taking off as a species.
Get ready.
Alright man.
Maybe see you.